All right.
We're alive.
That's it.
You don't have to do it Chris.
Don't worry about it.
Alright Chris,
what's going on guys?
He paying attention.
What are you doing?
Hello Chris.
How good you're doing.
Checking your email.
We're alive is a million people fucking Christ.
Let me see my Facebook.
Oh,
I got a like on that picture
you guys are the head of the owners of my favorite all time website for mixed
martial arts.
It's changed names three or four times since I've been a member.
A submission fighting.com back in the day.
Right?
What was the original,
the uh,
the original,
well I grabbed a bunch of URLs before the sport.
Really had a name that would have been 95 ish or so.
One of the ones who grabs with submission,
fighting.com I asked the guys at the gym at a submission,
fighting.com mixed martial arts.com and a few other ones.
What they liked,
they said submission,
fighting.com so we ran with that for a few years.
But I would get outraged emails from people saying this is not what I was
expecting.
And what they wanted was one of those sort of porno apartment wrestling kind of
sites.
And then my mother said she would tell her friends what I was up to and she'd
say,
they'd say,
what's the URL?
And she'd say,
submission fighting.com and she'd get long looks from him.
So after my mother started complaining,
I changed it to mixed martial arts.com then the UFC switched to UFC TV.
So we became MMA TV and then we,
and then the UFC dropped the TV.
So we went back to mixed martial arts.com that's where we are forever.
Although somebody offered us a,
they offered,
they didn't complete 600 grand for mixed martial arts.com and we would have
dropped it in a heartbeat for that.
And going back to MMA TB,
why didn't you take it?
And we did take it.
They didn't.
They didn't to with the one changed.
Yeah,
it's all yours.
600 grand.
$600,000 that's insane.
Didn't business.com go for like 7 million bucks or something crazy like that?
Yeah.
What the fuck,
man,
that's a lot of God.
Damn scratch.
The one that kills me though is I turned down mma.com for $200 at the time,
cause it wasn't a sport,
really wasn't mixed martial arts.com.
It's like people called it that,
but MMA wasn't really a thing yet.
It was the main mall association and they had,
they had let it lapse and for 200 bucks I could have grabbed it.
And I'm like,
yeah,
$200.
It's a lot of money.
What year was this?
[inaudible] 99,
maybe 98.
99 97.
Somewhere in there.
Do you remember what year it became called?
Mixed martial arts?
All the whole sport.
I would,
I mean I would date that to when everybody got to get,
when nick limbo got everybody together in New Jersey and came up with a unified
rules,
which would have been 2008 crash.
And that's when,
uh,
that's when the,
the name sort of started to stick,
but they were calling it that did big John McCarthy name it.
I have heard a variety of,
uh,
I've heard a variety of explanations for where the name came from.
And I honestly don't know.
I don't think there's anyone that's a that's that's definitive.
I'm pretty sure our heard big John say that he named it.
It was either him or it was Jeff Blatnick.
I can't say it.
Yeah,
more than once.
Jeff has said that he coined the term and the aspect John Cause he's up at the
San Diego with us so we get back on the CFI claims that what is going on in San
Diego.
A character and myself are up there for our convention.
It's the association of Athletic Commissions.
It's a blast.
It's all the athletic commissions in the country coming together for a year and
drink and just pretty much talk to each other about the issues are going on in
their acs and they try to,
well obviously not for a year.
How long has it go for?
No,
sorry.
They come together every year.
Once a year.
It's a like a week event for them and they just go over rules and shit like
that.
It sounds a little,
there's a huge amount of socializing and it sounds a little bits that's
trivializing it.
The thing is the,
the,
uh,
association of boxing commissions was formed by a Federal Lola Muhammad Ali act.
But that law has no teeth.
There's no penalties if you don't pay any attention to suspensions and does
nothing happens.
So the whole association is basically built on goodwill.
So there's an awful lot of just people getting to know each other and having a
beer.
And Chris often acts as a bartender and gets to know people that way and sounds
like it's a little trivial just to get to know people,
but it's actually the glue that holds the whole ABC together.
So that's how it holds together.
Like say if somebody gets banned in,
say Mississippi,
they keep them band in Massachusetts and things along those,
that's it.
Exactly.
The,
uh,
the Muhammad Ali act says that,
requires federal law,
requires that boxing commission share suspension information.
So you kick it,
knocked out in Boston,
and then next weekend go up to New Hampshire and get knocked out again and then
go to Maine and get knocked out again,
which used to be a real problem.
It's still is a real problem in places like Mexico.
Mexico doesn't out suspension,
so guys just literally will,
if they're,
because they're poor,
they'll get knocked out every weekend and their opponent,
you know,
everybody's bogged away.
MMA is built on fair fights from the beginning of,
of is built on tomato cans.
And so there's a huge market for fighters that just lose,
um,
and they get knocked out all the time in Mexico.
Right.
And like that guy that fought Mickey Rourke and Russia as this insane losing
record and he's homeless somewhere around here,
actually [inaudible] guy who lives in the streets and his job is basically to
show up and get knocked unconscious.
And I didn't even do a good job of it.
That was bizarre.
It's bizarre.
Did those things still happen?
Like did you see the one in Mexico,
the politician that muscles,
the guy with a huge chest?
Yeah,
that was,
that was absolutely.
Have you seen the crews?
No,
I don't think I've seen it.
You need to say it.
Well,
we'll play it to Fox and match.
Oh,
it's reject.
It's kind of call it a boxing match.
It's a guy who has synthol injected it to his arms and chest and shoulders.
You know that synthol stuff.
If you don't know,
people are listening to this synthol something that I guess bodybuilders created
it because like if they had a body part that wasn't sticking out enough that
like wasn't symmetrical.
Like say some guys,
their calves don't grow very well.
So they would have these big,
upper is big leg,
but their calves would be skinny so they would inject this oil into their calves
and it makes your muscle swell up,
but they're like fake boobs.
They Jiggle when you move.
So this guy has it all over his body.
He has it on his shoulders,
he has it on his chest,
he has it on his arms and because of that,
first of all,
his arms are heavy.
It's like he's punching with like 10 out 10 pound gloves and the other guy has
eight ounce gloves and this guy is known for having fake fights.
Apparently he has like 11 fake fights on his record and he's a senator in Mexico
and he's comes from a wealthy family.
The guy on the left,
massive plastic surgery all over his face.
His whole face looks like a like a fucking Kabuki mask.
But look,
he's,
his whole body is like fake.
And if you turn it up Jamie,
so we can hear when the crowd sees him fight,
they start laughing like really loud.
Like give us some volume here.
I was like this on the crowd.
I mean jet the fuck out of here.
That's like a sketch from mad TV.
Said,
look at this,
look at the way he's throwing punches is literally like he's got led all over
his arms cause these Goddamn synthol muscles like he's carrying pounds of this
water stuff is oil stuff in his body.
I would fight that guy,
that guy on the left.
We'll either,
one of them I guess
is so crazy.
This guy's a law graduate.
Wouldn't have to do to be a law graduate in Mexico.
Pay The fee.
I mean
have you guys might want to suspend that guy if he's still a lawyer.
But you know,
it's so crazy because Mexico is known for its great tradition of fantastic
boxers.
Like some of the greatest boxers of all time I've come out of Mexico.
It's a huge part of their culture.
So to have this guy do that,
it's rich guy do that is,
it's so crazy.
But that's always existed.
I believe that was a,
was done in the Philippines.
I think Mexican fans would pull that guy from limb to limb.
If you tried it in Mexico,
I'm pretty sure that was,
uh,
that,
that video was shot in Mexico,
in the Philippines.
That was it.
Yeah.
It's just Mexican fans are very,
very,
they're like Philly fans.
They know exactly what they're looking at.
It's just interesting you said that because the guys who were talking,
they sound like they have a Filipino accent.
You guys are speaking English.
I don't know the Filipino accident well at all,
but I definitely would defer to you.
I play a lot of pool and some of the Filipinos and the great pool players,
some of the best pool players ever from the Philippines.
So I'm used to Filipino accent.
Um,
the,
the website you guys started,
so you've been around for 20 years now.
Uh,
we started the site in [inaudible] 98 so I thought you said 95 95 I started
buying the Urls,
I think [inaudible] 96 we had the art of NHB fighting on AOL,
so if you started in [inaudible] 98 I was a member I think in 98 I think I was a
member like the first year then if not 98 99 somewhere.
I've got our first,
I think first 400 and you're definitely on the list.
I'm one of the first 400 baby woo.
How many members you guys have now
active?
Hundreds of thousands.
Probably.
Holy Shit.
Half a million accounts,
but you know those people fall off here and there,
but a lot.
Wow.
We have 1.3 million people that come to our site every month.
That's insane.
And growing and growing.
Well,
it's the best forum and it's,
it's hard to regulate,
but you guys have done an amazing job of keeping the Douche bags off or at least
keeping them at bay because that's what ruins those places.
It kicks off all the pro fighters like so many guys used to post there and don't
anymore like Tito and a lot of other like Evan Tanner of course there's a famous
thread that gets pumped up every now and then where Evan Chandler was saying
hello before he died.
And uh,
it was cool back then that like these guys who were fighting in the UFC would
come on on a regular basis,
but they get run off by these just anonymous shitheads who just say the root is
mean is shit to them after they lost or before the fight.
You know,
like I've talked to a bunch of fighters,
like no one even to name names,
but giving guys like John Fitch or like I don't go there,
I got to stay off their,
cause it fucking fucks with my head.
Like these guys are assholes.
I'll pretty much all assholes.
The problem is,
it's not true.
They're not all assholes.
But when we started it was a small,
tight knit community of people that were in the sport.
And then you know,
the UFC blows up so people find us and now it's a million people.
And out of those million people,
maybe 10,000 are nice,
but the rest are just anonymous douche bags.
I don't really think it's the,
I think it's the opposite.
I think 10,000 or cons,
the other rest of them are fairly nice.
And the concert,
very vocal.
Like they get it,
they're all in there all the time and they just speak up all the time.
Well,
it's just like they can.
Yup.
I mean that's the beautiful thing about the Internet.
It's the horrible thing about the Internet.
The beautiful thing about the internet is anyone can talk and that's the same
reason why it sucks.
Yeah,
that was perfectly,
that was perfectly put.
It baffled me so much.
I actually went to a psychiatrist,
ask him,
uh,
there's a psychiatrist as a friend of family.
I'm like,
why do people do that?
And he said,
human beings have all sorts of emotional impulses and we're constrained by
society from acting out in a lot of them.
Maybe you're an unhappy person.
You want to swear it,
every single person you see,
but you can't,
or you get punched in the eye or there's other bad feedback.
But on the Internet,
all that stuff just comes out and you're anonymous.
So there's no repercussions whatsoever.
Like occasionally you guys hear about that guy and read it.
He was a,
uh,
a famous,
I'm infamous guy on some of these forums because he would post like really
inappropriate shit,
really rude things,
nasty things.
And apparently,
I don't know if it was anonymous or who went after the guy,
but they found his actual identification.
They knew who he actually was and they contacted as employers and they sent him
the posts that this guy was making and he got fired.
And uh,
you know,
they interviewed him and he said,
it was his release.
He said he was just playing a role and you know,
he would do cho pictures of underage girls and all kinds of like really creepy
shit.
Yeah.
I mean that was his thing.
And uh,
it was real in real life.
I mean he got real live repercussions because he got fired because of it.
So it was,
it was a big deal.
Eventually,
it doesn't surprise me at all.
We have guys email us every week.
Can you please delete all my posts on your farm?
Because they're looking for a job I've had.
I don't want that stuff out in public.
I've had that happened on my own message board,
but I'm like,
dude,
you don't,
your name is like,
you know,
suck it off.
[inaudible] 69 he really thinks someone's going to find that.
It just seems like,
it seems like a weird place to look now when you started,
what's,
what's really interesting about this sport for folks who don't know?
I'm mixed martial arts.
When I came along in 1997 it's one of,
I first started working for the UFC.
It was essentially a band sport.
The only way you get it was directv.
That was the only way you could get it was banned from cable.
Uh,
and when you would talk to people about it,
they would talk to you like you are a horrible person for being involved in such
a thing.
And the sports stayed alive because of the Internet.
It was the first sport ever that stayed alive because of the Internet.
The websites will,
the sure dog or MMA weekly,
I don't know when that came along,
but there was a bunch of them that came along that that was how we found out
about the sport.
That's how we found out about the pride shows and k one.
And you know,
all the different fights that were going on in Japan and in Brazil.
The only way to find out about them was the internet.
So we were all like really active,
like,
and you would go to these forums and you would try to find out,
you know,
what is happening,
what's going on now?
And a lot of times,
you know,
you would,
uh,
be able to buy a tea.
I used to get tapes from a dude in Canada,
friend of mine in Canada,
uh,
had a friend and this dude,
contacted me do named Brian and I will buy tapes room.
He would get them from Japan and he would send them down to me in California.
I still have a gang of them and it was like all Genki pseudos old fights and kid
Yamamoto like in the early days.
And it was really the,
it was a such an underground sport.
Why?
It's one of the reasons why the name of your website was so perfect because it
was the underground of the underground sport.
Yeah,
I agree 100%.
I actually,
many,
many years ago,
maybe 15 years ago,
I tried to get wired magazine to do an article on it because they did,
maybe it was 10 years ago,
they did an article on the role of the Internet in revolutions in countries and
that was,
that was Tony.
I was like,
Hey,
I got a sport that was saved by,
by the Internet.
And they sent him some cool pictures and they were like,
oh,
those are cool pictures.
We're not interested,
but I agree 100% and I,
I tried to get some,
some notice
of that and the sort of the tech community or at least as much about the
technique as much of the tech communities I know which was,
which was is it wasn't as wired magazine.
Well there wasn't very many other sports.
I can claim that.
None that I could think of.
And what other sport,
first of all,
there's never been a sport in our life that has grown the way MMA has is
nothing,
nothing even close.
They tried it with soccer,
didn't take,
I mean there's been a bunch of attempts.
Remember when they had that basketball game they used to play on trampolines
all.
They still play that game.
I seen it on ESPN like seven to before.
It's like still on and like one o'clock in the morning.
And that's what they used to have.
Like Pka Karate,
PKA karate you to on it.
Like they can't give the eighties that's right.
That's what they called it.
But there was no sport in my lifetime that grew like MMA did from complete total
obscurity to the cover of ESPN over the front page,
front page of CNN,
a cover of sports illustrated.
Like that shit never happened.
There's never been a sport that that blew up like that.
And when it was at its worst,
when it was at its most desperate time,
it was sites like yours really.
They kept it alive.
Yeah.
Ultimate Athlete magazine listed again,
this is going back 10 or 12 years because they tried to compete with the UFC
with a show also using the term ultimate and they got sued and disappeared.
But before they disappeared they gave out,
they did the 20 most important,
um,
things in the history of the Internet and I,
number eight was the underground and they were like,
if not for the underground and several other sites of the sport might've died.
And then they went on to discuss exactly what you are because it had been banned
from television and,
and everything.
Well at one point in time,
the other ground had more posts and the underground,
it's still does does it?
Well,
we,
it got to be so much our surrogate full,
so we killed the other ground one day and everybody got mad at us,
but it's,
they're more or less even now,
more traffic on it.
We have to like every 30 days just delete them because it's just,
it's stupid.
It's these guys at work,
nine to five
they just found snakes in the Internet with some friends and they just stay
there all day.
When I worked some psychos and I worked nine to five,
that's all I did all day.
I was an it guy.
I would just,
Oh gee,
all day.
Well that's,
that is the thing about people that have desk jobs where they're not being
watched.
The amount of productivity,
that's a loss today because the Internet is off the fucking charts.
It is absolutely absurd.
If you look at,
our stats were only popular during work days.
We can smell really bothers you and they're going to a barbecue or taking a jog
or whatever.
Nighttime there came their girlfriend.
It's people at work all day.
It's amazing how much time is being wasted.
People are getting paid by the hour to serve to other ground and look at girls
acids,
young,
9,700 page asked threads that you guys have.
There's a,
it's a,
it's a testament to how things are screwed up in American management though that
did it.
It's
allowed.
I mean,
nobody should be able to go on the Internet during the work day because they're
not going to be doing work.
They're going to be
listening to this podcast right now.
There's a huge amount of people at work with headphones on that aren't doing any
fucking work at all.
They just kicking their feet back.
They might have like a folder open,
like they're pretending to pay attention to some fucking spreadsheet,
but really they're just listening to us.
That's normal.
I know that there's a,
there's a little thing you can download for your computer.
So at the touch of a button,
a spreadsheet pops open and makes it appear as if you're working hard.
So you boss comes and looks over your shoulder and being spreadsheet.
I didn't go back.
I wanted to work with Kerrick since Oh sex before that was just an it guy.
Graduated College.
I regular it job,
but I was into the sport and so I would work it eight to five and I had the
underground up all the time or I was doing work for him,
like on the side and I had a button on the floor that was attached to Usb and
when like tapped it like an excel spreadsheet would pop up and like another
document they're looking at,
I was working,
so if like a boss came in behind me,
tap the button.
It looks like I'm working,
but I'd really just be Oh gee.
And I working on something else all day.
You boss is listening right now.
He wants his fucking money,
right?
Yeah,
probably.
I think I owe,
I'm like 40 grand a year for three years.
Just something that really is a,
it's a giant issue.
Now another giant issue that you guys must've come across is bandwidth.
I mean,
how much bandwidth does that site use and how much does that cost every month?
I remember when I,
the first time I ever noticed bandwidth was an issue with $75 a month and this
probably would have been 99 or someone,
he's like,
oh my God,
$75 a month.
This is insane.
And then,
uh,
an ex you f,
ex NFL player owned a snake store in Colorado and he kind of heard,
I was having this huge $75 a month bandwidth issue.
And so he said,
you know what?
Put a banner on your site for my snake store in Colorado.
I'll give you 75 bucks a month.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is money.
This is commerce and what are we paying now?
Cars 3000 a month or something for it,
3000 a month,
3000 a month in bandwidth and bandwidth and all that fun shit.
That's insane.
And that's not including the cat,
you know,
the capital costs of the,
and we start drive,
go down.
Something crazy happens like fight related,
like just people saying what the traffic Greg is about to break the internet or
something and it happens all the time.
Kimbo is broken the Internet more than once.
Um,
Kimbo take moments that tend to break things.
Now when you go to the underground,
if you go to em,
mixed martial arts,
I've almost said MMA.
Dot.
TV,
it redirects.
If you go there,
you pay $500 a year to keep that just because half the people still type it in.
And when they go to a browser,
my browser used to be programmed to it.
I would hit em and it would,
that would fill it out,
click that and then it would,
it would forward to mixed martial arts.com but you got a bunch of banners like
you have a Mazda ads and do you guys have to actively seek those out in the
hall?
We have a company that pretty much wraps all of the ad inventory.
So made some deals
ourselves like with the endemics,
like the rev gear and draft kings and request a test fox,
but someone else just sells the rest.
And so now is this your job entirely for both of you?
Yeah.
Yeah,
a hundred percent a hundred percent wild,
isn't it?
Like at one point in time is must have been like a frivolous thing that you were
doing
for the first,
for the first decade or so.
Occasionally we would get ahead by a few hundred dollars and then there'd be
some local fighter.
I know we've got a chance to fight in the Nebraska.
I had a guy who had got to fight Nebraska,
so I bought him an airplane ticket.
That's what we would use with our super profits.
And then,
uh,
I don't know when,
when it,
when it turned pro 2008,
May,
2008 we brought in Chris and Chris kind of got some good deals and all of a
sudden I was like,
oh my God,
we can make more than $75 a month.
Yeah,
well not,
so when I came on board,
they were like,
we have this website,
it gets a million views a month.
We make $100 a month.
And I'm like,
I think you can make more than that.
So he's like,
hey,
try it in the soil and you've got a job.
So I reached out to like tap out the big guys in the space and I made big deals
that these guys were like,
you guys should go ask tap over 800 bucks a month.
And I'm like let's go ask him for 8,000 and see what happens.
And sure enough tap out bit at the time and kind of took off from there.
That's actually a true story and the numbers are not exaggerated in the lakes.
We were literally like kind of angling for 800 a month and of course literally
said 8,000 a month and they literally bought it and we signed a contract.
It's probably the greatest day of my entire life.
Tap out is like a a great example of the over saturation of the market.
Like tap out at one point in time was cool to wear.
I know a lot of people have a hard time believing that.
No,
19 1998 sophomore year of high school,
I ordered the tap out you're from and your face.com and I thought shit it said
like submit to tap out to cry uncle to it was like,
I was like,
this is awesome.
I wore it once a week to school cause I thought that was the best thing in the
world.
I thought it was so cool you wouldn't catch me dead in the tap out shirt,
you know,
before like nine years ago.
So now you can't catch you dead and tap out.
You're no,
not a chance.
What's it,
what happened?
I think they got related to like the Douche Douche bag aspect of MMA fans and
there,
there is that whole big culture of like Douchey MMA fans and like tap out then
affliction.
They all got kind of stuck in that.
Well how about how that happens?
Well I it uh,
grappling tournament again 15 years ago or something,
I had an interaction with a guy that,
that stuck with me ever since I had made some call in some mash and I came,
I think it was his match.
Not One of his students.
He's got a big school up in Canada now and he was arguing with me that I made
the point wrong and I was like,
dude,
it's just grappling.
Come on man.
And he looked at me and he goes,
look,
this is what we do instead of having health insurance.
And I just got cold apologized and I listened to what he said,
but there's a,
that's what he,
he said grappling is what I do instead of having health.
Sure.
So he pays for grappling instead.
Health and human rights.
So serious about his lessons at hens.
Hose that he had moved from Canada,
moved in,
moved from Canada to New York.
I was taking lessons at handles.
He was probably a bit of black belt.
Now he's probably a blue belt or a purple belt.
Then I was reffing a match.
I probably made a wrong call.
He lost.
I was telling him it's not that important.
And he said,
this is what I do instead of having health insurance.
I can't do both.
That's how serious it is for me.
And there's a hardcore fan base of the sport that's like that.
Like if you were like,
okay,
health insurance or never discussing or having anything to do with MMA there,
there,
sorry,
health insurance,
hope I don't break my leg.
But that's the hardcore fan base around them.
There's millions of knuckle heads that also by the apparel and stuff and
eventually the knuckleheads out number,
the,
the hardcores and,
and uh,
and it doesn't work.
The one huge,
et cetera.
One of the huge exceptions that those roots of fight,
it's just an unbelievable company.
They,
the very first time I saw one of the,
the of their,
uh,
their things and wearing one right now you're wearing one right now where their
shit all the time.
Not,
but that's too,
yeah,
I've got one in my,
I've got one in my suit and we're wondering where I've got one of my suitcase
right now.
They managed to do with integrity.
I think I see their,
their,
their apparel around a lot.
And to me at least,
they still have complete integrity.
If the president and the tire center was wearing and I'd still be like,
yeah,
we're to fight as is awesome.
It's a fight.
Takes old like fight promo posters and turns them into cool t shirts and all
like this one.
This is the actual sign for the Gracie Academy in like the 1950s and this is
amazing.
That's it.
To me it's like a little piece of history so I don't think they're ever going to
go out of style,
but there's certain,
there's a certain douchey element that's attached to the tee shirt world of
mixed martial arts because it became a way that guys,
it's sort of identify with the sport.
Like a,
this is one that I always site.
There's a real shirt that I saw in New Jersey.
This guy was wearing a shirt that said,
some guys grapple,
some guys strike,
um,
both.
And I was like,
Oh,
you're disgusting.
I actually know that company.
Yeah.
Some guys who strikers jump guys are grapplers on bull.
Mike,
my favorite Nma t shirt of all time is kicked out of the run off of it.
But a couple of companies have.
My girlfriend loves to grapple,
but you should see her box.
My favorite a teacher I've ever had,
I think I still have it and that's a good shirt for Boston to cause the word box
and synonymous with vagina in Boston and one of those.
It's one of those weird things that somehow or not,
I did not know that that was just a Boston thing assumed it was worldwide
spread.
We've,
we've spread it,
we've spread it across the world,
but I think it came from our neck of the woods.
I think box was like how the box doesn't even look like a box.
Maybe a Kleenex because I like the box at this hole in the middle.
How her tits cans,
tits were cans for a long time.
Right?
What does that make any sense?
Him,
I don't think any of the nicknames for tits makes sense.
Probably boobs,
but it looks like boobs.
Did you ever think at one point in time and not keeping that site going there?
Was there any time where it was becoming too expensive or too much of a pain in
the ass and you're just like,
ah,
fuck this place?
No,
the,
the worst of the sport is in some ways when I was the most dedicated to it,
when the sport got,
got off a paper view and yeah,
there was like three paper views in a year and that was more or less it hooking.
Shoot,
Jeff,
Jeff would put on a couple of Hook and shoots here.
There's almost nothing.
I figured the sport was going to die on a national basis and then we would,
we would just sort of build it up over 40 50 years and I'd be dead at the end of
it.
But I believe in a sport I always have and I thought it would,
it would build up from the bottom up.
And so I thought the Internet at the time at least,
was incredibly important to do that.
So on the sport was at it's lowest.
I was,
I was actually the most excited about keeping the,
keeping the site going.
I've definitely never,
uh,
never a single moment wanted to turn them off one at a turn it off cause all the
jerks.
Well I always had loyalty to cipher.
A couple of reasons.
One because it was one of the first ones I've ever joined and it was like one of
the places where like I said you would get guys like Josh Barnett would post on
there and all these yeah a lot of guys,
big guys,
Randy and the back of the day get Henderson,
Dana white would be on all the time back in the day and he's still on it every
day.
He just hasn't,
it doesn't post anymore.
How do you know,
cause he calls me though once a week to complain.
Oh Jesus.
Does he complain about like posts are up here and there.
Yeah.
You know,
it shouldn't have actually spread that he's getting a match.
just as people were like making things up above them.
He doesn't like that and people right now are going to be making things up right
now because they know that you guys are here.
Right?
I mean when he says stuff that he says it,
he doesn't care.
But if somebody twist his words and make something up,
he gets upset about it because that's why people do it for fun.
I,
yeah,
the whole trolling
through how many they're going to continue to do it now.
Dana,
Jesus Christ Christian three under the fucking bus.
I just got like,
Hey,
I'm going to get a call and like 10 minutes like you're fired.
I always had loyalty for two reasons.
One because of that,
but two,
because care can I,
we know people from from Massachusetts like we knew like we're probably pretty
close to same age.
I'm 47 how old is four 54 we in that time period,
we knew a lot of the same martial arts people like I'd heard about you,
I heard about your school in western Massachusetts.
Western Massachusetts was always a home of Larry Kelly who's like a really well
known karate guy.
Here's my business partner for 20 years and he was really popular or famous
rather for knocking out Billy blanks back when Billy Billy blanks was a fucking
superhero.
I mean he was the point karate guy and that's another one where they dusted the
guy off and made them fight again.
If you watched that fight with Billy blanks,
Larry Kelly chaos him with a hopping hook kick to the face and Larry was famous
for his hook kick,
which is a really hard shot.
It's a hard kick to generate force with because your have to start out here and
then they have to switch that way.
It's a weird motion.
Whereas like around kick seems more natural like kinetically.
But Larry had a down he and he hook kicked Billy blanks in the face and send him
fall lying.
He skid across the the mat.
He was completely unconscious and they waited for him to wake up and then they
were literally trying to get them to fight again.
That's how this is it right here.
Oh here it is.
Watch this.
This is uh,
like when people talk shit about the hook kick,
I say,
well I'm going to show you something here.
First of all,
Bill,
super foot walls and boom that,
I mean,
come on son,
look at that.
I mean that was beautiful.
One more time.
Look at this.
The hop boom and he disguised it behind the back fist or a jab or whatever he
was doing with his front hand.
Beautiful.
And when uh,
they've dusted him off after that,
if you watched the actual full video,
they were trying,
they waited for a long time.
They were trying to get them to go back in there and fight again,
which is how stupid people were back then.
This terrible,
they had no knowledge when we were coming up and we were talking before the show
started about guys who had been knocked out in the gym and all these people that
we know,
people get knocked out,
they would dust you off and push you right back in there like that day,
five minutes later,
like right here,
is Billy there w there warming them up.
They're like,
wake up Billy,
wake up.
Wake up,
it's like,
I think I got a dream.
It's called Tibo smelling salts and his nose.
And there was a,
there's was a bunch of these guys,
there was him and a bunch of other guys like him that were these really big
super muscular guys that were involved in the point fighting circuit.
And they got real good at leaping in and tagging you and um,
you're starting to see that skill emerge in MMA.
I know there's a guy who fights for Bella tore his name is escaping me right
now.
He's a venom.
What's his venom Michael Page,
right?
Yeah,
that's it.
And he has that style.
And then of course you've got,
um,
uh,
Raymond Daniels who's fighting and glory,
who's really picking up the kickboxing game,
who also was a great fighter in a point karate circuit.
And he's got that style,
that leap in style and the ability to cover distance,
the,
the ability to jump in and cover distance in a way that you can't,
you know,
like there's a lot of guys that are,
uh,
they're sticking to that Moy Thai style,
sort of flat footed Tiago Silva Plod forward sort of style and that shit is not
flying anymore.
You got these guys like Tj Dillashaw that are now using the neo footwork style,
but the Raymond Daniels style,
I think that's the next level.
I think you've got that style of leaping in on top of the neo footwork style
because that ability that those guys had of his closing the distance really
quick with that karate style blitz.
I still think that's like a missing aspect in a lot of MMA.
Machita had it a little bit,
you know,
he has,
he has an element of that,
but he was more of a counter striker I think.
Um,
Larry Kelly like in that,
in that video,
like demonstrated like why that can be like super effective like that.
It actually came,
originally came into the sport of,
uh,
point fighting from a Bruce Lee in Bruce Lee picked it up from,
from fencing.
Bruce Lee watched all kinds of,
he watched boxing and loved Muhammad Ali the same way Dominick Cruz did try and
pick up things from him and he watched fencing and it fencers have the quickest
footwork,
handwork that I personally have ever seen.
They just explode forward.
And he picked it up and he showed it to a karate guy named Joe Lewis,
not the boxer,
Joe Lewis.
But I cried.
A guy named Joe Lewis and Joe Lewis started smashing everybody with it.
And so everybody else picked it up.
And then the point fighting in karate where you stop every single time you land
sewing,
which is kind of nutty,
started to dissipate and people start doing what's called continuous point where
you weren't trying to knock each other out.
You were trying to land super clean shots without a knockout,
but you kept going.
And that's where like Daniel's came from.
And I'm Michael Van and page and guys like that.
And I,
I do think that it,
uh,
that it can be applied to the sport and then,
you know,
in a couple of years people learn how to counter that and something,
something new will come along.
But when you can do something new in the sport,
you get a,
you get a little edge for a while,
like Machita did with,
uh,
with his traditional SugarCon karate,
the,
those long,
long lunges forward and sort of jabbing super hard and throwing that right hard.
He had an advantage over everybody until he started bringing karate guys in and
they're like,
okay,
it's not that tough to shut down
guys,
figure out what they're doing.
You know,
once you find a guy who's really good that you can spar with,
then you can kind of time it.
But until then,
until then it's like,
what is this,
this new style of movement that I have in front of me that I don't,
I don't know anybody moves like this and it's super hard to judge.
She provided judge the timing.
I got to watch it organically,
most notably through a,
through grapplings,
I started reffing grappling in the late nineties for my best friend Kip Cola or
with,
with Naga and I would watch as new grappling techniques would get introduced
when I started,
nobody knew what a heel hook was and then a few guys would learn a heal hook and
guys didn't know how to it.
They didn't know how to tap.
They didn't know what break your leg if you didn't tap.
And there'd be these horrific injuries of guys spinning the wrong way from heel
hooks and now hardly anybody taps to heal hooks.
It's not that tough to get out of.
Um,
and unless Paul Harris can sound,
then you're in trouble now.
Mother Fucker,
Jesus Christ,
she's terrifying.
Or Eddie Cummings or,
or
Gary Tonin.
There's a new level of guys that are coming and the grappling circuit out of a
John Danaher school and it's like this,
this new level of leg locks,
like leg locks are really permeating all of grappling in Jujitsu now and are in
a very new and strange way.
I've had some interesting conversations with Eddie Bravo about it,
where Eddie really ignored leg locks until a few years back and then started
incorporating it.
And a lot of it is because of the success of a lot of these east coast guys.
A lot of it,
like I said,
Gary Tonin,
Eddie Cummings and a lot of it is under the tutelage of dawn her,
but there's a lot of guys in,
in grappling that are really good at it.
And of course in MMA it was Paul Horace.
It really kinda opened up a lot of people's eyes.
Yeah,
it's funny you brought it up.
I'm going to train with it tonight down in La.
And I told someone that and they're like,
yeah,
he's been really working on his leg lock slightly.
So that's where you can just look out for my gym.
Coincidentally we've been doing leg looks forever like Joe Lozo and those guys,
that's the bread and butter they've been doing.
Flying heel hooks is for 10 years and it all came from uh,
a guy named Donnie Danville and fall river.
Um,
it was actually passed now,
but he grew up with a Japanese mother and judo and um,
he was like a leg lock king and this is like 2002.
And we're like,
what the fuck is a leg lock?
But he came into our gym and he tossed like rolling toeholds he taught us to fly
in leg lock.
MMM.
All inside,
outside the up,
all that stuff.
And we're like,
this is awesome.
And for years our gym was,
we had,
that was a competitive advantage.
We knew leg lock,
so he guys and grappling tournaments and fights with Lego blocks and they had no
idea what was going on.
Do you guys remember Scott Adams?
Yeah,
of course.
And he was guy,
one of the guys who trained with chuck like way back in the day,
he was known as like a leg lock master back when no one knew what the hell leg
locks were.
He was one of those guys that you would hear about and you would go to him,
you know,
there was a few of those guys,
like Frank Mir had some real good leg locks way,
way back in the day and that's,
that fucked him when he fought Ian Freeman.
Remember that he was going for the heel hook.
What do you really,
wow.
That was when it wasn't working for the UFC that was watching that at home.
And uh,
I,
I remember that was the issue with leg locks was that when someone would attack
a leg lock,
you would have both of your arms committed to the leg lock so you wouldn't be
able to defend against punches.
And as you know,
with a guy like Ian Freeman,
it only takes one to scramble your fucking senses.
And then a cop I'm in,
frank got hit by like four or five in a row.
Boom,
bom,
bom.
He just was gone.
You know.
And it's interesting to see that the progression of these techniques,
how it changes and how it morphs.
And one of the things like from like if you look at a guy like Larry Kelly or
you look at it like a lot of these traditional karate techniques,
those,
those techniques were kind of looked at like,
like there was those don't work anymore.
But now you're seeing so many of these traditional martial arts techniques like
front kicks to the body are now standard like Collin Mcgregor,
Conor McGregor rather ruined Chad Mendez with front kicks to the body.
Just jabbing them with those front kicks to the body and the spinning back kick
to the body.
You've seen a lot of guys throw those kicks to the body.
Now you're seeing a lot of wheel kicks that Wonderboy Thompson files.
Fuck Jake Ellenberger.
Holy Shit Shit.
I mean you're seeing these traditional techniques that are just super effective
when you get them in the hands of a guy like Edson Barboza when you get them in
the hands of a guy who knows all the other things.
Yeah,
I couldn't agree more the at various points I have thought,
okay,
the sport is is done.
We've SORTA got this body of knowledge and we've just got to refine what we've
got and we're not going to be seeing a lot of,
a lot of new stuff coming
in.
And every time I had that thought,
six months later,
something had come along and,
and uh,
I would be proven wrong,
including super simple things like the arm and guillotine when it first started
happening in grappling tournaments,
I was reffing first time it really hit me hard.
I was reffing in Hawaii,
guy stuck in a,
in an arm and guilty and I thought it was a front headlock.
And in Naga you give points if somebody gets close to a tap and I'm standing
here like this is nothing to go on.
It's a front headlock from Heidi to dump.
Dad is not going to,
and like I went to sleep cause remember Pete Pete,
Sal and Phil Baroni Pizza [inaudible] sleep and Phil said after the fight he
goes,
I didn't know that you could get the sleeping one of those.
Right.
Cause we did know it wasn't that he was ignorant,
we didn't know.
But Matt Serra,
who was Pete sells coach knew they were a little bit ahead and use the Jujitsu's
Henzel Gracie black belt a little bit ahead.
You know a little bit ahead of everybody.
When I started learning Jujitsu,
I was told you're safe if the arms and your friend had like,
oh just hang out.
You know,
let go and you're good.
You're always safe.
They figured out how to get up high on the neck.
That's what happened when guys started getting that Guillotine,
they would lean back like a regular gauge didn't work,
but now when they get up high on the neck,
man,
it just shuts the lights out.
If you've got a good grip,
you know,
there's also different grips like this is a big one that a lot of guys are
using.
This Pretzel Grip where your wrap around this way,
it seems awkward until you have someone's neck in there and then for some reason
it feels amazing.
Yeah,
I know Jake shields likes it.
I learned it from Denny proper goes,
who was a big fan of a,
he's a big fan of like adding,
incorporating all kinds of weird grips to it.
Be Different people have different grips that they use with techniques and it's
amazing how just those little subtle adjustments have a huge impact on the,
the,
the efficiency of the technique.
How much leverage you can get into the technique.
Yeah.
I think Tom Waller told me that was his grip one day and I was like,
I'll try it.
It seems weird,
but I liked that grip now and it's a great grip.
So many,
so many.
One in Mexico with a guillotine and then,
you know,
did like motion to the camera.
They went like this and they were like,
no,
no.
Like this.
Like he did it to the camera,
showed after he got the tap.
I get the name escapes me,
who it was.
But uh,
that's,
it's fascinating to me.
All the different techniques and the different variables and we're seeing that
even with the traditional martial arts techniques,
there's still a lot of things that guys are doing wrong with like traditional
kicks,
like sidekicks and spinning back kicks are turning side kicks.
There's still a lot of guys that have the need down instead of the knee up.
They don't lift the knee high enough because it takes,
it takes a long time to learn how to do that,
but when you do do it,
then you get that thrusting kick,
which just has so much more power.
Like Barboza like you see Barboza is turning side kicks this weekend.
He lifts that knee up high and it comes straight at you.
That mother fucker kicks so fast.
Can you imagine getting kicked and the deck like oh his name dead from that
spinning back kick,
he'll write to the deck.
I don't know what kind of copy has,
if it's one of those diamond MMA ones or one of those tie steel cups.
The didn't will
just supposed to be like,
you can run him over with a car and they don't have one now.
Yeah,
that's what I use.
They're incredible.
They're great.
Do you have one character?
There are 100% I can actually do one of those.
Kicked me in the Jimmy skits and you can get kicked in the Jimmy and it actually
like those commercial,
they put an apple in the cup on the ground and they run it over with her.
I get a cup and it gets destroyed.
Then they put it on the Diamond Cup and they run it over and the apple is fine.
Yeah,
they're legit.
4,000 pounds of a car or whatever.
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting cause all these,
you know,
these little problems that people used to have and they still have,
there's a lot of guys that still have lush,
shitty old cops.
Like I don't know what Felder was using,
but it looked to me like a regular jockstrap and a comp that you would buy a
fucking a sporting good $10 shock doctor or something cup.
I was cornering a rocks.
And so a few years ago at a strike force and uh,
we were,
we were just,
I think we're just taking a long walk to shoot trucks.
Roxanne modifiers.
Yeah.
It was the same one where a fade or knocked out a Rogers and I think,
um,
uh,
come on,
spit it out.
Ah,
Ha has some,
uh,
mental health issues right now.
So yeah,
he's a long list.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ
I ran into may have Miller and he had his cup and it was just a cup that you
would buy for 1495 at,
at Dick Sporting goods or something.
Um,
the metal cups are,
I think they're the best because if you kick them,
you get a broken toe and if you figure four somebody's body,
you can dig the Metal Cup under their spine,
grapple at the cup.
Now I feel like I'm not confident like I'm going to like move and then like,
ah,
just a cup.
Well,
the metal cups are banned from a lot of grappling tournaments because they offer
a,
a weapon.
Yeah,
it's a weapon.
It's,
it's um,
it's like a leverage point,
like a fulcrum point.
Especially for arm bars.
It's like you're,
you have a rock there.
It's a completely different point of leverage then you would have,
if it was just your deck,
I won't,
I wonder if that's how big Tim's forearm broke when Mir did.
I wonder if he had a metal cup on it.
He couldn't have forearm over the edge of the Metal Cup like that.
I never thought about that.
Very possible.
You guys fight with ty Cobb steel cuts.
I tell everybody to.
Joel ozone has this mount back Ma and he calls it broke back mountain.
So he gets like,
so he gets the hook set right?
And then he's got the hooks that he flattens you flatten the ground.
Then he scoots his ass back.
So like his cups and you're like you asshole pretty much.
And it's terrible.
It's terrible.
I've tapped out to it cause he just drives forward with a hot cup and it feels
like you're getting fucked in the ass.
So you've got to just be much tap.
Well,
you kind of are
probably no penetration,
but it's pretty close to it.
That's so rude and terrible,
but you can't move.
You can't.
We be like stuck because you can't like push your hips up to the sky.
It's terrible.
There's some moves that are still legal in grappling like oil checks.
How's,
that's no,
that's illegal in NCAA wrestling.
That's,
that's wrong.
You are literally shoving your fingers in a man's asshole to controlling him and
they move because of that because it fucking hurt.
That's horrible.
It's weird that you could do that,
but you can't just grab his dick.
You want to really manipulate a guy grabbed his dick.
You can move them around.
I mean if you think about it,
if a Fishhook is illegal,
why should be,
we'll put your finger and the guys,
but I mean that's totally a hundred more times.
Do we think there's a bunch of stuff that needs to be changed in the rules,
like downward elbows.
That is just dumb,
dumb as fuck.
Every time I'm at the show,
I watched the raft tried to explain that elbow guy.
Yeah.
And every ref is different and under the corners,
like what are you talking about?
Like there's like a fucking Mohawk.
Oh No,
no.
I mean yeah,
but that was the area 12 the 12 to six elbow was banned because in big John
McCarthy told me this,
that when they first brought the sport to the athletic commissions,
they said,
okay,
you can do anything but you can't do this.
Downward elbows try.
Cause I saw a guy on ESPN break bricks and a karate tournament.
So they,
they thought that this was the most powerful strike known to man.
Meanwhile you've got Barboza wheel kicking Terry Edom into another dimension and
that's legal and also like the back of the head.
Like I get the fact that you,
she,
you don't want people to get hit in the back of the head.
But here's the reality.
Almost every head kick is landing in the back of the head.
That's why guys go out.
Cause that the foot wraps around sitting in the back of the head.
Yeah.
It's a big part of it.
A big part of the impact is the instep or the Shin.
Literally hitting that spot where everyone tells you not to hit when you do
ground and pound.
But little short punches.
I mean it's kind of funny,
like someone's telling you,
you can't hit a hammer,
fists in the back of the head.
You know when your arm is half tied up and you're trying to do that and they're
like,
watch your back of the head.
But meanwhile when you're standing,
you just crank it with all that thigh meat and bone and 50 pounds of leg behind
it and boom,
that's legal.
It's very strange.
The A,
the thing about the back of the head that a lot of fans don't know is that both
players have a responsibility and that what usually happens,
especially with those kicks is that kickstarts to come in and people shy away
from it because it kicks coming in and they expose the back of their head and
then they get knocked out.
Um,
but both players,
both fighters have a responsibility about that back of the head stuff.
And if a shot comes in that if you hadn't moved,
hit you on the side of the head and then you move and your back of your head
starts to get exposed.
It's kind of on you.
Well,
the same on the ground as well,
right?
When a guys pounding on you on the ground and you're moving your head away from
the punches to your face and he hits the back of your head and the referee says,
watch the back of the head.
Well you were already launching that punch before the guy turned.
It's kind of not really your fault.
Get agreed 100% of science behind the back of the head thing.
I mean,
isn't it bad to hit any part of the fuck I want?
Any part of the head is not good to hit from boxing.
It was cold,
a rabbit punch and box.
And going back to before that,
it's always been illegal in boxing.
I had a,
I had a weird one two years ago,
the Association of Boxing,
uh,
commissions convention.
I spoke with a surgeon who was one of the,
um,
uh,
ringside physicians,
a group heads,
and I was like,
I asked about this exact thing,
this exact thing we're discussing.
I said,
you know,
how dangerous is the back of the head?
And he said,
you know,
the one that I'm worried about is right here.
He said that before either,
well,
that where the,
apparently I didn't know anything about it.
When we're little kids,
the bones haven't quite grown together.
And as you get a little older,
up until two years old or something,
all the bones come together and they form an a little spot right here.
But the,
um,
but uh,
he,
he thinks that there's actually a weakness in being hit right here.
And in the 80s,
I remember being at Master toddies when we tie studio in Manchester,
England,
and we watched the videotape and tidy said that guy died on the tape.
And I was like,
Holy God,
how did he die?
And it was a downward elbow right to here.
It's like a,
sounds like a silly sort of a blood sport thing,
but that jumping downward elbow right to this spot here is illegal and Moyie
Thai so may will be actually that's illegal.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the single downward or the double downward where they jump up and come right
down and hit right here is illegal.
So that's so strange that the forehead would be an illegal target.
And Moy,
Tai,
that seems so busy
with an elbow,
but a downward downward elbow.
What about like a slashing Alba?
Totally fine.
Cut cutaway.
But it seems like,
but even a hard one,
like I was strong elbow.
It's still,
I mean it's not that specific.
If you're hitting someone in the forehead,
it may be as simple as a few times guys go,
well a lot of times it will be Thai guys had been downward,
you know,
wing elbowed across the head and they didn't die.
They just got a big cut and then somebody actually passed away from the straight
downward and they were like,
oh,
we're not doing that.
But the problem is in Moy,
Tai,
you're not dealing with the most stringent athletic commissions are doing Mris
and cat scans and making sure that people have the EKG is in order.
There's none of that going on there.
So who knows why the fuck that guy died.
And a lot of people speed,
they take speed before they do more.
Cause more.
Yeah.
That's pretty common.
Kids kids died of it and they in Thailand,
Dak younger,
younger,
uh,
several law younger fighters died from,
they would take speed cause you,
I mean I don't some kickboxers back in the 80s,
it took speed for the same reason.
He kind of trained harder.
You get more aggressive,
you're more angry,
you feel pain less.
Do you remember rip fuel?
Yeah,
I did.
I took that shit once.
I went to Jujitsu class.
Oh my God,
I almost fucking died.
My heart was pounding was Saul tall,
tall,
tall.
And I was like,
I got to sit down like I've never been,
it wasn't tired.
It wasn't a tired thing.
It was like my heart was racing.
It was like I shouldn't be this tired.
My heart shouldn't be beating
and then try that in a fight.
When you are adrenalized and you're bleeding and he's bleeding,
the referee screaming,
there's 2000 people screaming and imagine what your,
your heart would have done.
Yeah,
guys have guys who have died from it.
People did die from rip fuel.
It's one of the reasons why,
I mean I remember taking it and I remember a,
I rolled with a couple guys and then I just had to sit down cause I was,
I was,
I was really concerned.
I was like this is not like me being a pussy.
There's something going on here.
And then I heard about all these people dropping like flies and then they pulled
it off the shelf and then they made it illegal.
But I would take it before I would lift and I feel like fucking Superman,
I'd be,
Oh God,
you just have so,
but lifting,
you know,
you're doing sets of six or whatever the hell you're doing.
It's not taken you that long.
When you're doing a nine minute role,
that's when the heart really starts getting taxed and it just can't recover.
It can't calm down.
It's just you're confusing the signals with that goddamn speed.
Friend of mine and a little,
I don't want to call it a seizure,
but he,
little CP Lee had a little hit,
a little Caesar,
a little seizure while we were driving.
We're driving a Honolulu and all of a sudden he just kind of pulls over and
freezes and shakes and it was,
it was from rip,
rip,
rip fuel,
that word.
You know,
if we'd been on the highway,
I don't know what would have happened.
He would've died.
I would've died.
It was a rip fuel oil.
You would have reached over a fucking heroic manner and sat in his lap and drive
due to safety.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's interesting how there's all these different,
like crazy athletic supplements that kind of go by the wayside.
They start out being like a,
like Jack Three d was one that I think have they pulled that final,
they pulled that,
cause I know that somebody like guys in the military,
apparently we're taking it.
I have a buddy of mine who was in the military and he told me about it.
He texted me,
he goes,
you ever tried to Jack Three d?
Holy Shit,
I'm getting big on this.
And then like four months later somebody died on it.
I was like,
I sent him the article.
I'm like,
man,
my understanding is that that unscrupulous companies will come up with some new
formula that's got two horny goat weed and oyster meet and who knows what all in
it.
And they will actually add real anabolic steroids to it.
Oh yeah know they'll market it,
you'll get huge.
And then they'll take the steroids out.
But the stuff's still has a reputation.
So it's,
it's back.
You can still buy it.
Well,
find out Jack Three d basically changed the,
uh,
maybe they changed the,
the 100 mil or something like that,
who just Google Jack Three d deaths mean.
So I might have to apologize if I'm wrong.
Death armies.
He was wanting to death after using Jack Three d points to gap and regulation.
But it could also just be a guy that just died.
She,
that's the problem.
It was like,
who the fuck knows what's killing these people?
You know you don't,
I don't
know.
People die just jogging.
They do die.
They die with nothing in their system.
They die with just fucking salads room,
you know?
And if the guy had died and he would have died anyway and he just took Jack
Three d and died,
you could blame the Jack Three d but I don't know a lot of Goddamn people
tearing.
Remember red line.
It was like a drink.
I remember taking that.
Someone's like,
hey take this,
let make you feel great for your workout.
I thought my chest was going to blow out of my fucking heart.
I like,
I thought that I'd never done cocaine,
but I feel like that's what cocaine feels like.
Like it was like [inaudible] and I had to rack off like four hours and I went
home and he was still jacked up.
I never took it again.
It was terrifying.
Well that stuff was also like many doses in a bottle.
Yeah.
Like he'll drink like a quarter of the bottle,
but it's not a big bottle.
It's not like a can of coke and you look at it,
you're like,
oh this is a serving,
but you don't read that.
Who the fuck reads labels like those look like this shit in the back.
Like the little tiny I can,
first of all I'm 47 my I suck unless I put reading glasses on.
I can't read that.
So these little things I could have to go,
okay,
how many t four four servings says three ounces of liquid.
How's this four servings dividing this with team,
that pint of Ben and Jerry's,
they tell you that's four servings to,
but it doesn't need the whole God damned pint of Ben and Jerry's.
That's where tick.
But that's like how they get away with like,
you know when you look at a bag of chips and tells you how many calories or is
per serving only 183 checks.
But it's,
it's interesting how the supplement industry when it comes to bodybuilding and
when it becomes to any athletic training has really benefited from all these,
you know,
these different like regulations to get past where new things become illegal.
So they come up with some new thing to kind of like fill in the blanks.
It's I one of those guys that did always,
uh,
I've never taken very many supplements because I've never made hardly any money
from doing it.
And I figured if I was making some money I would definitely take every
supplement on the market because it was worth it.
But it was never very good and they weren't probably made more than $200 or
something.
So I,
I,
for me it just,
it wasn't worth it.
Making money from fighting.
Yeah,
make money from fighting.
It just was,
might as well just go in there and see how you do.
So percent natural.
Talk about the what,
what's going on right now with MMA,
with the testing because I think it's pretty fascinating that this is a sport
where to be completely and totally honest,
most likely a giant percentage of the population of the people involved in the
sport.
We're taking some sort of performance enhancing drugs.
It seems like to get through a training camp,
and if you're not familiar with MMA,
one of the crazy things about the sport is that it involves so many different
disciplines.
You have to learn how to wrestle,
you have to learn submissions,
meaning you know,
joint locks and chokes.
You have to learn how to kickbox.
You have to learn all these things and you have to put them all together and you
also have to do a strength and conditioning program.
So unlike boxing where you're learning how to box and then you're probably doing
a little roadwork on top of that,
but that's mostly it.
It means some guys engage in some calisthenic programs.
Manny Pacquiao is like his famous ab routine.
He could see him do a call.
The lab actually does.
Palati switch is kind of interesting,
but they don't have to grapple.
So for them what's important is just honing those hand skills recovering and
coming back and honing those skills.
It's really,
it's,
it's counter productive for them to go through the same kind of workouts that
the MMA guys do.
But for MMA guys,
this fucking grind of getting up in the morning every day and doing this for six
to eight weeks for a camp,
it's almost impossible to do at the highest levels without
some kind of help.
And now the UFC has incorporated this rigorous,
incredibly intense testing where they're doing randoms five times a year on
people.
So guys like Conor Mcgregor,
Liotta or anybody,
they're just going to get tested.
They're going to show up at your house.
And if you have to,
if you're in camp,
this is what's really fucked up to me.
Say if you've got to work out at 10 o'clock in the morning and you,
you know,
you need your sleep,
you went to bed at 10 you know,
you're,
you're looking to get 10 11 hour sleep and they wake you up,
they'll wake you up at five six o'clock in the morning,
pee in this Cup right now,
and you have to,
and the,
and they wake you up,
they fuck with your sleep and you know,
yeah,
they're only going to do it that one day.
But you might go to the gym that one day and be tired because of that.
And that might be the time you get injured.
It's totally possible.
It's totally unprofessional.
It doesn't make any sense to me that they're allowed to just wake you up.
They should.
They should have to do it in an an off time and a time where you absolutely are
not going to be getting your rest.
Like you should have parameters.
Like she said,
listen,
I go to bed at 11:00 PM every night.
I wake up at 9:30 AM and when those times leave me the fuck alone cause I got to
recover.
God,
goddammit.
You know,
but they don't,
they don't do it that way.
They just come anytime they want and they you have to
pull out your deck and in a cup and that's it.
There's watch you two guy has to watch a Jake.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Cause you could have a rubber dick.
Kevin Randleman got busted with a wizard Nader.
Well Kevin Randomly got busted with non human urine from w well from the wisdom
of the horse you're on or something.
But guys will do everything that cheat.
If you're not looking at their deck like you can rub like like a paste on your
thumb and like let your stream run through.
It wasn't either as or the in this area deck,
he's got to look at it and you're like the piece coming out of that deck and the
paste was somehow another diffuse diffuse would go through your finger and the
paste whatever the ingredients where it would diffuse the sample or a tainted or
I think it's a good thing to find out what everyone's taking.
I think it's also a good thing to try to figure out what,
what is possible for the human body.
Like what,
what kind of condition can you actually get in without help?
I mean and if we are really dealing with a sport where 70% let's say 70 Vito
says is like 90 maybe he's right.
I would say have used at some point it's 90 I'm using right now.
I have no idea.
But at some point in their career we're using,
yeah,
it's 90 do you think that's the case at other sports?
I have no idea.
I know a fair amount of what mixed martial arts,
but like I wouldn't know which end of a tennis racket.
The hold I,
I don't know.
Although Chris,
Chris and I spent a yes,
the good part of yesterday with two of the two senior guys from Usada and for
hours.
They talked about everything that they've gone through since ever since.
And U S anti-doping associate,
that's the,
that's the group that uh,
the UFC has contracted with to do all the testing.
And when we look at it,
it does seem completely onerous,
but from their point view,
they've been in a decades
long battle to against people,
particularly in well in a lot of sports,
including maybe most notably cycling where they told us a story yesterday about
one of their testers and they found this out later years,
years later in deposition,
one of their testers shows up at the hotel.
Somebody is waiting in the lobby and cell phones up.
That guy is on his way up right now.
The athletes sprints to the doctor's room and the doctor grabbed an IV bag and
squeezed it and forced it into him and then put another one in and squeezed it,
enforced it,
and there was enough extra liquid in his body from that.
So as levels were a little kind of weird,
but they didn't go over any threshold.
And that's the kind of shenanigans that,
that they've been fighting against.
And I think that's the origin of that stuff.
Like we're going to show up at 3:00 AM and we don't really care about you in MMA
to it.
It does seem completely unnecessary,
but from their point of view,
with this decades of of Toronto fight dirty cyclists and things,
they,
they feel like that's the corner that they're,
they're forced into.
We'll cycling is the dirty sport.
It's the dirtiest,
I think.
Right?
It's one of the dirtiest.
That's why I saw something in the dance.
Some guy who was winning the Tour de France and I just started laughing.
I'm like,
what's he doing?
Is He doing,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Do it while you're lying.
Who Cares?
They're riding the fucking bike.
I,
they ain't trying to hurt anybody.
Let them all do steroids and just see who wins.
And when you can't,
you can't do that because then the idea is that kids coming up are forced to
take performance enhancing drugs cause otherwise there's no way to win that
sport.
It's a fake sport.
It's a fake sport in that the results that you're seeing are not normal results.
They're superhuman results and they only come about because you take a guy and
you alters chemistry.
You alters chemistry to point where he's not a human anymore.
Like if you look at a bodybuilding,
yeah,
look at a body builder,
perfect example,
and you look at some fucking giant Dorian Yates type character,
just veins all over his eyeballs and his fucking faces ripped and he weighs 300
pounds and is five foot two.
It doesn't make any goddamn sense.
They're like,
what is that?
It's not a human,
it's just not a humanities or levels that they have in their body or not human
levels.
There's,
this is a new thing.
You've created a new thing with chemistry.
Yeah guys.
Of Guys,
you know those body builders will put on 70 pounds of muscle and as anybody
knows who trains putting on seven pounds of muscle is,
it takes years to put on,
you can put on 10 pounds of muscle in six months if you are fucking really
diligent and you got to push through really hard sore days,
you got to do a lot of dead lifting.
You got to do a lot of squats,
you got to eat a lot of fucking meat and you gotta you gotta.
You gotta really work at it,
but you can do it.
You could put on,
most people don't work out that hard,
but if you get a guy on the juice you can put on,
I was on this stuff called Mag 10 you should be able to buy it at GNC.
You remember this?
Oh,
you're selling these pills.
These are cell GNC.
They're like clear pills.
You take like 10 of them.
It's like some crazy number.
I put on 10 pounds of muscle in like seven weeks.
She says,
I'm not even kidding.
It was legal is a strong as shit I've ever taken.
And when I got off of it,
my Dick died like a sniper.
My Dick was useless.
My Dick was useless for like a month.
It just wouldn't work.
And I was like,
wow,
that's,
that's a steroid.
That's a real steroid.
And it was one of those things that you could just buy for a little bit.
It was like the little window,
you could buy it and then it went away.
But I'm telling you,
I never got bigger in my life off of anything other than this stuff.
And I felt so strong.
I would go to the gym and like one day I'd be able to get 10 reps and then I
would my next workout,
four days later it was 12 reps didn't make any sense.
I'm getting an extra two reps in in three or four days.
Like that doesn't make any sense.
But you would just recover.
And then I would think about what is it like to take like Anna draw 50 or some
of the really crazy ones that they say turn you into like a wild silver back
gorilla and then stack them,
right?
Yeah.
Those guys,
they would take him like I remember a,
I knew the student was a football player who told me that they would take an
Adderall 15 and we take all this different stuff and uh oh no,
no,
no.
This is a different guy.
He's a bodybuilder.
He told me he was a,
became a Jujitsu guy,
became a black belt under John Jacques Machado.
Great Guy.
And he told me that when he was bodybuilding and he took the Ana draw 50 stuff.
He said literally he would see red and then wake up grabbing someone about to
kill them.
Like he would like some guy said something to intro him in traffic and before he
knew what he was out of the car reaching into the guy's car,
ready to kill him.
He was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I don't want to go to jail.
I don't want to kill anybody.
But it was this overwhelming rage for almost nothing.
It just turns you into like an animal.
Like it sets you back.
Like you're strong as a Gerler and he,
you lose that like cumin parties fucking little thing.
Not really a person.
You're some,
you're like you mostly person,
but you've got some other element in you and the Ana draw 50 stuff is
apparently,
I don't know if it still is,
but that was like the stuff that people would talk about.
Like if you fuck with that,
like that is that,
that's the ranger,
that's the ranger and that's the stuff that puts 30 40 pounds of just stacked
shredded beef on you.
Just
all those dudes that would do squats and drop the bar and walkaway.
Barely human.
Okay.
Guy At my gym in the,
this is going back probably early eighties doing karate.
Nice guy from a couple towns over a move to la.
Started bodybuilding,
got a girlfriend,
got pissed off at her,
got a bat,
broke her window and she shot him dead and he was not,
he was not a violent guy.
He never been convicted with,
never been arrested for any crimes,
didn't do anything bad.
I really do pin that on him.
Just sticking every steroid he could possibly find in his ass until his brain
blew up and then his girlfriend literally shot him dead.
Well,
there's a dude that I knew that died.
His name was Curtis and he was vittores original strength and conditioning
trainer
back in 97 when Vito was 19 years old.
Remember when Vito first in the UFC?
Vito weighed about 200 plus pounds,
like two two oh three maybe maximum.
He was a real lean,
but muscular is hell and fast as lightning.
When Vito first stormed on the scene would never seen hand speed like that with
good wrestling and Jujitsu too.
I mean he just,
Trey telling men had no idea what was coming.
He came out guns blazing.
That guy that was training and we would like Eddie Bravo and I,
we used to call him garden hoses because the guy had veins that were like garden
hoses.
They didn't make any sense.
He had these arms that were like,
I'm not bullshitting.
Five of my arms,
like maybe five moms rolled up at a cord.
I mean there were enormous,
but he had veins throughout his arms that were like hoses.
He's she huge fucking veins and he was purple.
He would lift legs.
Ooh,
Julette tricep extensions.
And it would be purple.
Just fucking,
the whole thing's about the blow in one day it did and one day it's just blue
pop,
boom.
The whole thing just,
just left him bleeding internally and just the whole thing exploded.
Harder brain,
it's a pot,
the whole fucking
catastrophic failure of everything.
And he was in his thirties he was a young guy,
you know,
and that was when Vituro got up to like two 40 when he fought Randy couture.
Remember that?
I mean he got just shy like a lion.
He didn't even look at a person anymore.
His head looked like it was attached at the top with a neck.
Like his top of his head was where his next start and it just came down and he
just had no gas is gas tank was for about maybe 30 or 40 seconds of flooring.
And then it would like quickly drop off.
Was that the fight that ended in like a minute with a cut on the,
I know that was in,
that was for the light heavyweight title and that was in the two thousands.
This was way before that,
I want to say 97 or 98.
And I was there for that fight and a Vituro was like 240 pounds.
That was when,
uh,
everybody thought he was gonna kill Randy and Randy just beat him down,
took him down and smashed them,
mashed him,
changed his life.
Like if Itar before then was this unstoppable force who had destroyed tank
Abbott destroyed tellig men and Scott for Roseau.
And everybody was like,
Vito is the fucking,
like people were talking about VR versus Hixon.
There's all this like this crazy talk back then,
you know.
And then Vito had like that downward spiral that he went on for a little bit.
Whereas his sister got kidnapped and all that stuff happened after that,
I found her right.
She died and she was killed.
Unfortunate,
horrible,
horrible story.
Um,
but uh,
but the point being that like performance enhancing drugs there then it's not
all fun games.
Scary Shit,
scary shit.
And when you force your body to do something totally unnatural like that,
like the,
the rapid change of putting on 30,
40 pounds in literally six to eight weeks like that is not good for,
is not good for you though.
So we got to stop that.
Right.
But the dialogue is like what,
what should be legal?
It should it be legal to take creatine cause that helps.
Should it be legal to take amino acids because they help.
She'd be allowed to take volt multivitamins.
Should you have to get all your vitamins from food?
You know,
where does it end?
One of the ones that,
uh,
in that regard that I've been puzzling about for,
for several years now is a Nick Diaz heads.
He's,
he's used to cut a lot over the eyes and there's a surgeon in Vegas that will
cut your eyes open and a grind down your eye orbits.
So they become less sharp.
I Dunno.
Is that cheating?
I mean,
he's doing surgery to change his body so he can be a more efficient fighter that
it's kind of defensive.
He's just trying not to get cut.
But
I dunno,
it,
it had been thinking about it for years and I don't know what the answer is.
See that one,
I don't have any problem with it all because he was born with just a weird
eyebrow.
And also,
uh,
on top of that,
he had so much scar tissue from all these fights.
So it wasn't just a matter of the bone was cutting his,
it was also a matter of like,
he had to get that scar tissue removed cause it would just burst,
you know,
scar tissue.
If you don't know when you have scar tissue around your eye,
when something heals up,
it's measurably weaker than it was before that.
But now they have new methods of dealing with that.
Like Vandelay like before Vandelia got his surgery,
his eyes,
he would just get hit once and it would swell up and it would like come down and
almost closes I and then would cut open and start bleeding.
And if you looked at them back then before he had his surgery,
his eyes were just a mass of scar tissue like all around his eyebrows.
So it makes everything thicker because you've got all these cuts,
the heel and there's a not and another one that healed and there's a knot and
all of his time is happening.
Your eyelids are relaxing also from getting hit a lot cause the muscles get
pulverized and it starts drooping down over your eye.
So some guys get surgery to sort of raise their eyelids back up and put them in
place so they could see better cause you,
you,
when you are fighting for a long period of time as the Pooka look like you
always see it in cartoons.
They get that thing will get you what bullish they'll go,
nothings brained in that thing where they would get with the eyebrows would drop
down.
That that impedes your vision slowly.
A lot of guys also don't realize that Scott inside of your body takes a lot
longer to heal than the outside.
So guys would get cut in the gym and like three days it looks like it's healed,
but it's really still damaged inside go.
They're like,
oh,
it's not an open wound.
I can go back to sparring and they get hit again and it cuts open again.
It takes a long time for that stuff to heal internally and it becomes chronic.
Yeah.
One thing I wanted to throw in,
because there's a,
a huge audience here,
and I know it was a fact,
a lot of them are fighters is when you do get cut,
don't let like the EMT or somebody just throw three quick stitches in there,
get that cut done by a,
uh,
get it,
get it done by a plastic surgeon.
It makes a huge difference.
Although that scar tissue comes from people letting,
I've actually seen EMT is just,
I know how to do that and they'll,
they'll put three stitches in and not very nicely.
So guys,
when you get a really bad cut in a fight,
go,
go find a plastic surgeon.
It's,
it's worth it.
Yeah.
Well Kevin Ross,
he fought in lion fight.
He was actually putting pictures on his Instagram.
But what a shitty job the doctor had done.
They stapled him,
the staple went in the cut like instead of skin skin,
the staple.
This guy was fucking blind.
Some old doctor,
something stapled literally inside the cut instead of on the skin itself around
the cut to pull the cut together.
This fucking idiot stapled the cut.
And now a lot of times they just try to use glue.
I cut myself in the winner from a fucking icicle cause I live in New England.
It fell in my circle.
Cut You.
Yeah,
my fucking dad wanted me to shovel his roof off cause like they get water,
dams that damage.
So we're just pushing the lather up and he bangs nice sickle and I just look up
and fucking smashing me in the head.
I turned around and scream and then I look at it and he was like,
you're fucking bleeding.
I'm like,
what do you mean?
That grabbed my head,
fucking blood pouring down my face everywhere.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
So I go to the bathroom,
like put my hand on it,
go to the bathroom and there's a good cut.
I see a lot of cuts in the gym,
something like that.
Thick fucking needs stitches.
I'm like,
Dad,
I got to go.
I need tickets.
He's like,
no,
put the bandaid on it and finished my roof and then you can go into the yard.
So the panty though.
Wow.
I climb up that roof shoveled the roof,
goes to the ER and they want to put glue in it and I'm like,
I see a lot of the stitches like can you put such as in my head it's like,
I think we can get away with just glue.
I'm like,
get away.
I box like I don't want it to,
I want it to be really well closed.
He's like,
no,
I'm just going to put glue in it like can you please ditch it is like,
who's the doctor here?
And he just put glue in my head and it's still a big scar there and it's just
not as,
I don't think it's as healer.
It would've been if he gets his name.
What's his name is?
Fuck,
I don't know.
Wow.
He's an arrogant Brockton hospital.
So Brockton,
blockbuster and the part of the Marvin Hagler part of the story that Chris isn't
telling you,
is it like any good person from Lowe's and haven't made the minute he got a head
cut and he was bleeding all over the place.
He did a selfie.
Oh yeah.
When you're walking in a little gun,
guys in the jail of Famer,
he gets cut.
I'll be like,
don't wipe it off.
Don't touch it yet.
We've gotta take a picture first and then we like address the wound and stuff.
Why?
I don't know.
It's kind of like our wall of fame almost put a Polaroid up.
You got to move into your Massachusetts south shore to get out.
There are too many animals there.
It's just a fun environment.
Joe Even said it and then any of you this week for his fight,
he goes,
we're a bunch of pricks in my gym and it says we're all from the northeast.
They're all pricks.
Well,
I went to your gym and long time ago and he did a seminar.
Old Jim.
Yeah,
I remember me back in the day.
We actually,
uh,
we still have the toenail clippers.
We used it and we call them the Joe Rogan toenail clippers.
I don't think anyone uses them because they're like dull as shit now,
but like,
oh,
they're still sitting in a desk somewhere.
That's hilarious.
Why we were talking about this before.
Like anybody who doesn't clip their nails,
their,
their fingernails and toenails before they grappled,
that fucking sucks.
They scratch the shit out.
It's terrible.
You're talking about nick to tooth scratching your neck out for listening.
[inaudible] cut your fucking nails.
Do I carry a toenail clipper everywhere?
If I,
you know,
if I have a bag,
I'm going to work out.
Plus also to make a fist,
even though like a punch
the bag and into your,
your,
your fingernails digging into your fucking the meat of your hand.
Every people don't,
people don't cut their fingernails and don't take showers before they roll or
just bad evil people.
Some people when you a,
when they fight,
they do it on purpose.
You could tell they fucking stink.
Some people stink when I interview him.
Ooh,
you know they're doing it on purpose.
Lynn Lynn told me,
does it on purpose?
No showers for like five days and no,
don't brush your teeth and just take your arm pit.
They call Tawanna filthy because he's filthy like it's not,
it's not like a cute nickname.
He's fucking filthy all the time and just like eat food off the ground and not
shower.
You just be gross.
And that guy sweat like a motherfucker.
So like he's always nasty.
Think about his knockout that was craze.
Awesome.
I was in the corner for that fight and I'm like watching it from the corner.
I'm like,
shit,
he's getting beat up pretty bad.
That motherfucker big flat two or five are way bigger and just sitting there
like,
ah,
this is not going right away.
And uh,
the round ends,
we go in there and John would,
this sneaky guy,
he's talking to him,
he's like,
you know,
you doing all right.
You're doing all right.
Just stay in it.
And then the ticket around starts and he gets him with a hook like from hell,
like the best hook.
You get every headache guy walk through a few and miss before that he was
rounding to like 10.
No,
that round,
like right before he knocked him out.
It wasn't like Verlanti shouldn't have seen it common like he was throwing a lot
of hooks,
but Valencia was convinced he was going to steam roll.
He was running forward hard.
He ran right into it and ran into it.
I mean it was the perfect right hook.
It was picture perfect on the button and that he kids strong and he hits fucking
hard a wrestler.
But no Tom too.
Oh Tom,
physically one of the strongest guys have ever been on the mat with most
wrestlers are always strong.
You grow up wrestling,
he grew up throwing bodies around and manipulating bodies to develop a strength.
It's very unusual like Ben Aspirin,
you look at their Guidon look strong.
He looks like a regular guy but you talk to people roll with them.
They're like Jesus fucking Christ as he strong.
Yeah.
I read an interview with Pettis and Pettis City just tortures him on the mat
straight away with them.
Different kinds of strength and they've been throwing buys around cause they
were four years old when wrestling's grueling.
I've gotten a wrestling practices it like just like like a d three college
program and the grueling practices for hour and a half shoot across the mat for
20 minutes and drill.
It's,
they just build functional muscle for years and that sport,
I found a a a guy at a Iowa who did his phd on the changes in wrestling rules
over a maybe a 50 year period or something.
Red.
Red is just thesis and it was interesting and you can see they call them
concession holds and that submissions but it's the exact same thing.
You could see year by year,
decade by decade,
they,
they took out every dangerous hold from wrestling.
But curiously are interestingly by taking out every dangerous hold,
it actually made wrestling better because it's the one part of combat sports you
can do as hard
as you want and nothing gets broken.
You can't do Moitai.
You can't box 100% all the time.
You sure camp uh,
puts a and enroll on the dig into Jiu Jitsu when people 100% but by virtue of
having taken all the concession holds that a wrestling,
you can wrestle a guy just as hard as you want and nobody has to go to the
hospital.
And I think that's,
that's what that,
that's what makes wrestling so phenomenal as you,
some of these guys start when they're eight years old and they'd go as hard as
they humanly can for 20 years and they're,
they're monsters.
Also the mental toughness.
And they developed as a mental toughness that wrestlers possess because also
they're usually dehydrated.
They're cutting weight,
they're irritated,
almost always overtrained almost always.
So he developed this ability to push through discomfort that a lot of people
just don't have.
You know,
Jujitsu,
you can go full blast,
but you have to tab.
And if guys don't tap,
that's when problems occur.
But you can certainly go full blast up until the moment when you have to
concede.
But you know,
a lot of people don't like to concede and that's where the problem comes in.
This is one of the dumbest things people don't mind if someone scores a in them.
In basketball it seems normal.
But if somebody taps you,
it's like the end of your life because you're in a fight you would have lost.
But guess what,
as the only fucking way you learn,
like you have to put yourself in positions where you,
you're going to tap and you got to deal with that tap.
And if you don't do it,
you're never going to get good at it.
And we've all known so many guys that come from kickboxing that for whatever
reason they got really good at one sport and they never could get good at
Jujitsu because they didn't want to roll with people who could tap them.
Hmm.
Yeah.
The,
the,
I was like that,
you know,
I,
I opened up an MMA gym and way before I knew one single thing about the sport in
[inaudible] 93 just a couple months after a UFC one and for years and years and
years,
I just didn't want to tap if some new guy came in,
if he was a blue belt,
that's when blue belts are kind of a big deal.
I would lose my mind at the fear that the guy might tap me.
And then I read an interview with Frank Shamrock and he goes,
oh,
I tap all the time.
And I was like,
oh,
oh frank shamrock tattoo.
Oh it's okay for me to tap.
And uh,
that,
that helped me a lot.
You ever seen in Marcella Garcia and Damien Maia Role?
No.
It's really interesting.
Really interesting cause it happened left and right.
Sure.
Tap each other left and right and they,
they're not even going full clip.
There's sort of flowing.
They'll,
they're both so good.
They're both such world champions and they're not,
they don't have any ego at the,
you know on the line there.
They just trying to train hard and
get their work in.
Have you guys seen the clip of high end and Henzel rolling.
Yeah,
it's my favorite role clip of all time on youtube in their brothers.
So there's kind of be that sibling rivalry and in the end Henzel catches him.
But I was actually talking the big John last night about the same thing and he's
like,
cause he has a gym up in Valencia,
which is pretty close to here.
And he's like,
when the guy comes into my gym for the first time,
they're a little like star struck,
but they're close.
They want to change it to and he rolls with them and he shakes hands and they
going to start and he taps him three times.
Is that cool?
You tap big John,
now let's some fun.
So they kind
of get over that like,
oh,
he lets them,
he rapped him.
Yeah,
he just taps him on the show like taps out and quits before they even start.
So they have that in their head.
All right.
I just tapped big John.
Cool.
Let's roll sound.
Let's finally break the pressure.
I guess that's stupid.
I might be stupid but just last night John.
Oh Big John.
How dare you.
I think after that so guys can't go after him.
It's,
you know,
you get some guys a football player.
Yeah,
he's good and he's strong as hell.
Yeah.
He's a giant man.
He has a big man,
not medium.
John's very good.
He's not like this guy that like you say,
oh we changed you Jitsu.
He trains like he's really good.
Will you guys in Vegas for UFC one 89 I wasn't at.
My brother was actually in there.
I saw the photos you guys put on the Ugi.
Put some good,
good photos.
We did.
Where are you guys getting your photos from?
Like when you have those photos on the front page where it says like MMA news,
like I'll click on it right now is a bunch of photos.
Where are you getting those dolce exclusive on ivy ban.
Where are you getting that photo?
I'll be a screen shot from a screenshot.
From a video or Mike Dolce is a Facebook.
Oh,
we did.
We had a guy on the ground and get the journalists out there for that.
We got some good interviews and stuff,
but yeah,
the jungle shrugger yeah,
he goes every now and then.
He's an Irish guy.
He's like,
Hey,
I want to do some videos for you guys and go to the shows and we're like,
we really can't afford that six fucking expensive to send the guy out and pull
them up.
He's like,
no,
I just want to go.
I'll just do it on my own dime.
Like cool.
Go out there and have fun.
We get credentialed so he,
that's all he wants from us.
Really.
UFC one 89 was probably one of the craziest events ever been to ever.
I believe it,
UFC one 89.
I wasn't there live.
I saw it on a,
on a big flat screen,
but it was one of those few times that I'm like,
ah.
It was the,
it was the,
uh,
the Rory Robbie fight where I looked at the screen at one point and Rory looked
like he didn't have a nose.
Like I'm looking on the high def screen and there was no no's there.
And it was one of the very few times I've,
I've just been like,
I'm not sure I want to watch this.
And it was just too
intense.
That was one of the most intense title fights ever.
Roy McDonald got you mean they got,
he got so close to winning that title.
He had Robbie Lawler almost knocked out.
He had kicked him,
Dinged Dumb,
Robbie was wobbling and then Robbie came back to stop them in the next round and
his nose exploded and he literally went down in pain and you could see him
writhing on the floor and it looked like he was just trying to find some
comfort.
Like the pain was so intense when that broken knows that he was just trying to
find some kind of comfort.
Blood was everywhere and it was just two guys that push themselves to the brink.
And unfortunately,
when you see a fight,
what does that,
can you go to the bathroom?
So what you're saying,
just ask.
All right,
go ahead and go to the bathroom.
Jesus Christ.
Dad,
guys drinking over here.
Chris Palm Courses.
The only one drinking here,
throwing down the booze,
checking his fucking Twitter every five minutes.
But uh,
the,
it was,
it was a sport or it was a fight rather with these like you see him here,
like writhing in agony like here,
like that is so hard to deal with.
I mean,
he's just looking at him,
he's like,
oh,
he just goes down.
I mean,
he's just in agony.
it's one of the most tense moments
I've ever seen a fight of.
Just like the most obvious expression of the,
of pain.
I mean,
look at him here.
It's crazy.
He might not ever be the same.
Yeah.
Neat.
By the way,
Robbie too.
That was a crazy fucking fight.
Rory said the next day.
That was the greatest day of his life.
Yeah,
I'm sure he gets what kind of,
uh,
that's the,
that's the man he is.
I mean,
he fought his heart out.
There was nothing left for vault of them.
They were so closely matched,
such a good fight.
And Robbie,
how about when he's screaming in victory and his lip is split open like a cleft
palate is Lyft has split open this giant Gash in his lip.
Like look at them.
There's a sideways photo where you see like a profile picture of him roaring
with his lip split open and it's,
it's this hard to believe that this guy's,
you know,
that he fought like that.
He fought with his lip split wide.
If there's a better picture of a Jamie find it,
it's like a sideways angle of the side where you see the actual cut itself.
But it was one of the most gruesome lip injuries I've ever seen.
And you know,
it was the guy won that.
Those guys there is Dana.
Dana apparently walked up from that side right there and said,
oh my God,
don't talk.
Say Man.
Yeah.
I mean his lip was literally just a giant slice,
like you get hit with a hatchet in the face.
It was crazy.
It was a crazy,
crazy,
crazy fight and one of the most intense closely matched title fights in the
welterweight division history.
Yeah,
ever.
It was about down to the wire.
I mean it's really the kind of fight that everybody was wanted from GSP,
but she has fees.
Fights were always really tactical,
is really smart about when to take guys down and people would get mad at like
the way GSP would fight,
you know,
they would say,
oh,
he's just out pointing these guys like,
but that's the only way you get out with your fucking head and not getting
fucked up for the rest of your life.
This is what fighting is.
I mean,
what is fighting is fighting two guys hitting each other until one guy goes down
or was fighting,
figuring out how to knock it hit,
I mean the,
there were smart guys figure out how to not get hit as much.
You're always going to get hit.
There's no way around it,
but get hit the least amount possible and I don't understand people that get mad
at that.
I really don't like what do you have?
I always want to say,
does anybody ever hit you?
Do you understand what these guys are trying to do?
They're trying to not get hit.
It's a big part of this whole thing.
Don't get hit giant park.
My sense is if I was,
I'd never played football in my life and I barely know the rules when I watch
football personally cannot
appreciate their athleticism I it because I don't know what's going on.
I know that NFL players are probably the best athletes in the whole world,
but I can't see it cause I don't know the sport.
And my sense is there's a lot of MMA fans that just don't understand the
artistry that that goes on there.
The timing it takes to take somebody down and all the nuances of,
of defense.
And I think if they did know it,
they would love watching.
I love GSP fighting as a fight clinic.
Look at that guy for 30 seconds and I picked up sewing.
I didn't know before.
I love watching the guy fight.
But if I didn't know much about the sport and be like,
ah,
I just,
why don't you guys hit each other and give each other a bloody nose?
It's more exciting.
Well that's a lot of people felt about the Manny Pacquiao,
Floyd Mayweather fight.
A lot of people were mad at that fight.
Yeah.
It's call it boring.
You don't think he's trying,
I mean it's a fixed voguing mood decision to know each other.
Oh my God.
Just that stupid conversation that you have with people that don't understand
the sport and why does it need just do,
Oh gee,
you shut the fuck up.
Why doesn't he just,
well you should be coaching the fan and the grounded punch man in the face like
that's good advice.
I'm trying to punch him in the face.
I'm excited by the next level athletes and the next level ability that you're
seeing this sport that I think Tj Dillashaw shows like the those kind of guys.
I think you're going to see a guy like eventually who can move and strike like
Tj Butt kicks like Edson Barboza.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you're going to see that with a guy who could wrestle like Johnny
Hendricks.
You're going to see that with a guy who could submit guys like Damien Maia.
Like right now we're still in this growth stage.
We haven't hit the critical mass yet.
We haven't hit that.
That one where we see the perfect Michael Jordan of MMA,
they don't exist yet.
I think you're starting to see glimpses of these possibilities and what TJ
showed this weekend I think is a great glimpse of that possibility.
And that's what excites me about fighting.
Like people think,
oh,
you're a fucking meathead.
You like watching people beat the shit out of each other.
And it's like,
I get it,
I look like a meathead.
You know,
I sound like a meathead.
It's a,
it's a crazy sport being a cage fighting commentator.
It's,
it's,
it's a crazy sport to,
to be a part of.
People would assume that you like some sort of an uncivilized fuck head,
but my take on it is that we only live for shorter amount of time anyway.
You live and you die and there are extreme exciting things that you can do with
your life if you so choose to.
I think fighting is one of those things.
And I think at the very highest level what it is is problem solving.
It's intense consequence,
problem solving.
And when you're looking at a guy like Tj Dillashaw,
he has created this problem solving solution with Duane Ludwig and their,
their problem solving solution involves incredible athleticism,
amazing determination,
and a fanatical coach who has a deep,
deep understanding of movement and striking in a way that I don't think any
other coaches have.
The Way Duane,
this guys is so different.
I've,
I've worked out with him,
man.
He's,
he's on another level,
like he's all fucking aspergers out when he's,
when you're talking to him,
he gets crazy.
OCD,
a,
d,
whatever the fuck it is.
He,
but he's a blah,
blah,
blah.
Starts rattling out.
I've watched him and Tj hit mits together to,
to watch him rattle out information like the intensity level and the amount of
data that they're crunching and processing and how much thought is behind every
single movement.
You know,
a lot of guys when they throw punches,
like you say,
you throw a one,
two,
you'll sorta move a little bit full with the jab and then you rotate the
shoulders and the hips to throw the right hand.
Dwayne has the moving,
he's got you move with the left,
you move with the right,
your cons and you,
and after you throw that right hand,
you're moving again and you throwing a left hook,
you're moving again.
When you're throwing the right hand,
you're not just rotating your shoulders,
you're stepping in or you're stepping back.
There's all these movements and when you see it in the Barao fi,
especially that final flurry,
I mean that's some shit from a fucking movie man.
I mean,
he's going left and right and left and right.
He's not in front of them.
V toward trade.
Tellig men,
you know,
Ba,
Bam,
Bam.
No,
he's boom,
booms,
sidestep,
boom,
sides,
death and biologic shit and Borow is fucking seen a fireworks to spray at
Disneyland and he's throwing these,
his arms aren't working for him and he's throwing these hooks just trying to
stay alive and just pop,
pop,
pop.
He just getting lit up like a Christmas tree.
It was beautiful to watch.
It's a next level shit,
you know?
Yeah,
I agree 100% one of my heroes in the sport is Andre Petter narrows.
I think he's my hero first of all because he,
uh,
as far as I understand it,
he was the first guy to bring poor kids into Jujitsu and into mixed martial
arts.
It was a rich kid sport and a,
he would,
I mean you look at all the top guys from the gym,
they didn't have any money when they showed up there.
They'd live on the mats there and he played sort of a,
an avuncular or father role and,
and he brought him up and then he sent himself,
cause I've learned striking.
He went to what the holiday learned,
Dutch kickboxing and then he,
he welded a worldclass Jujitsu with Dutch kickboxing touch.
Kickboxing is,
is like American Western boxing and plus Moy Thai kicks and some karate kicks
and then a bunch of combinations.
In short,
that's what it is.
And he learned it.
He put those two together and he created guys like,
like Borow and,
and like Josie Aldo.
But now there's another step and it's that,
that,
that Bang Ludwig game.
Yeah.
The next level.
Shit,
it's,
it really is an interesting thing to watch.
It's an interesting thing to watch the progress.
It's an,
it's,
it's so fascinating because again,
if you look back at football from like the 1960s,
if you will look back and you watch some of the great players that played,
uh,
you know,
throughout history you will see better athletes today then you see then,
but the game is recognizable.
If you go back and watch UFC one from 1993,
I mean go walk or watch a Marvin Hagler fight from 88,
you know,
or 1985 march Hagler fight Mustapha Ham show or you know,
it was a great fight.
Great fight.
Why Watch him fight?
Do you know anybody?
Watch,
watch him fight anybody from,
from that era and then watch a really good boxing match today.
And you'll see the same thing.
You're seeing the same sport.
You might see a guy in Floyd Mayweather has who has it down to a science.
And I think,
I think personally,
as far as boxing,
I think Floyd Mayweather is the best boxer ever.
Cause I think he gets hit the least.
He moves the best and he shuts guys down the most.
You don't have to like him as a person.
You might think he's a Douche bag or whatever.
But I think as far as like being a skillful boxer,
it's my personal opinion.
I mean I got an argument with a Max Kellerman was telling me sugar ray Robinson
is the best and like maybe,
do you think that George,
do you think Jake Lamata would beat Floyd Mayweather?
I think you're fucking crazy if you believe that.
I don't think Jake lamata would lay a glove on him.
I just don't,
I don't know.
I don't believe that would happen.
I just don't see it happening.
And if they were the same weight class,
I think Floyd Mayweather would fucking pot shot Jake Lamata and tie him up and
cut angles on him and move away from on the ropes.
I just think he's better.
I think,
yeah,
Ray Robinson might've fought more times and fought more people and when all the
way up to light heavyweight and all that jazz.
But I think Floyd's the best.
But when you look at Ray Robinson's fights,
it's recognizable.
It's the same sport.
It's the,
it's the same sport.
This is a little bit of a difference.
A little more plotting.
They fought a little different.
They stood in the pocket a little bit more,
but Jesus Christ,
you look at the difference between MMA from 93 we go,
shit,
go to 95 look at MMA from 20 years ago and look at it now.
It's not the same thing at all for you watched Tj Dillashaw is fight the other
nine.
Tell me there was anybody that he was even remotely similar to that just 10
years ago.
I forgot about 20
true.
Was I a hazing?
I was talking with my own,
the records keeper for MMA and my counterpart,
the records keeper for boxing is Anti Vermont.
As a couple of two,
three years ago,
I was talking with Andy and John McCarthy and McCarthy was talking about the
fact that he owns a gym and he rolls with all the athletes and stuff and any
Mira Montes got kind of a weird look on his face and he goes,
wait a minute,
you,
you roll with these people.
Because in boxing you have to keep a distance,
a separation between the officials and the athletes.
And what Mccarthy said is this sport is evolving all the time and I can't do my
job unless I'm in,
they're actually rolling with the people.
And then he showed them a Google Plata and they,
uh,
Annie the boxing,
I was like,
oh,
that's unbelievable.
And at the dentist's several years ago to Google plot,
it was a fairly new move and he just threw that out as an example of how it,
boxing basically stays the same.
So if you're,
there are records keeper or you're a referee,
you are refereeing and officiating sport that's been the same for 50 years.
Basically.
You don't have to know all the new things in it.
And MMA is just all the time and if you're a an official involved in the sport,
you've got to be on the mats every week or something's going to be coming up
that you've never seen before.
Yeah.
In jujitsu there's always some new move that someone figures out.
There's always something,
some new way to do a choke,
some new way to lock an arm bar in or attack a leg.
That combination that Jamie just put up on the,
on the big screen,
this is a t J's final flurry against Hen Barao it you show me a painting than
anybody ever made that looks better than this.
Look at this.
The way he just did that,
the way he's moving on them and look,
every time his punching,
he stands in front of them.
He lands shots and then he moves.
Boom,
moves to the left,
moving to the right.
Look.
Every time he's throwing these punches,
he's movement.
I mean this is like a sponge.
Next level athlete and the kid like Tj Dillashaw super dedicated,
get a perfect mind for the sport that became best friends with a fucking maniac.
Like Duane Ludwig who was a world champion kickboxer who showed him how to do it
exactly how they did it in the locker.
I'm like,
I was actually back there watching them warm up and that's exactly how they move
with a warm up and he executes it exactly that.
He wants them to look at that,
that animated Gif like look at this movement.
I mean it's,
it's fucking incredible.
I mean,
look at that.
That is insane.
And right in front of them being,
and then slides just out of the way of the counter strikes says incredible shit
man.
I mean,
I,
I don't think there's been a guy in the sport that moves that good.
And what's really incredible is Dwayne never moved like that.
Dwayne's teaching them some shit that he figured out that he didn't even do
himself.
I mean,
Duane was a great kick boxer,
but Dwayne was way more linear.
Linear in his movements like with Tj is doing is some really crazy shit that
Dwayne sort of figured out that Tj can do.
And the maybe the craziest thing about it is Tj does have a base in something
else.
He started off,
obviously as a wrestler,
there's a whole new generation coming up.
They were on the swim team or they played hockey or more something.
They don't have any base in any sort of a thing.
All their learning from the Getgo is mixed martial arts.
Guys like Joe proctor out of a,
at a Christian was a hockey player in high school and walked into the gym and
never done any,
any kind of combat sport all his life.
And I think with the whole next generation of Joe proctors is,
is going to Spiro up stuff.
I can barely imagine.
Well there's a thought,
there's a school of thought that the best way is actually not that way,
but rather the best ways to get really fucking good at one thing to get like
really good at kickboxing and then dedicate yourself to learning MMA.
So you will always have this advantage in the striking because we all know that
to get really incredibly good at something almost requires like a singular
dedication.
Sure.
Like,
like although Tj is one of the world's best mixed martial arts fighters for
sure,
he's probably not one of the world's best strikers.
If you put him in like glory and you put him up like one of the,
the,
you know Andy wristy or one of those like really high level Moitai guys,
he might not be able to beat those guys.
But when it comes to putting all that shit together,
he's one of the best at it.
But if you get a guy like Andy rusty who learns all the shit that he's doing,
the t is learning,
then he will have an advantage over TJ at least in that one aspect of the game.
Whereas Tj will always have an advantage over him and wrestling cause that's his
base.
There's a lot,
it was an interesting schools of thought there that some people think that it's
best to learn everything from the get go.
Like a Rory Macdonald.
Yeah.
And some people think it's better to be like a Damien Maia where you,
you come in,
you have this one insane discipline,
the worldclass Brazilian Jujitsu and then everything else you've got to kind of
learn to go with it.
But worst case scenario you could always take it to that place and you'll have
this giant advantage over everyone else.
Like do you remember when Damien Maia took Rick story down?
Like rich stories is fucking beast of a wrestler.
Super strong guy.
But Damien Maia took him down,
smushed him,
transition to his back and squoze his fucking head like a Zit and I remember
watching it going,
Holy Shit,
I never let anybody do that to Rick story before.
But it's that next level Jujitsu that he has that no one else had or that you
know.
Very few [inaudible] that tape.
I don't know how I did the same thing to add Hermine as Hermoine was a team
quest guy,
good wrestler and he's like taking them down mountain and trial the right and
triangle and finished it and like this,
it was like when Danny and I went on that like three fights,
submission streak where he just ran through the tail.
Sudden remember we lateral dropped him.
Yeah,
lateral dropped him,
went right into a mounted triangle and tapped him.
It's like what the fuck?
And then just to take child down like that too,
to just fucking throw him like a rag doll was crazy.
He's the next level grappler.
But you know when he fought Anderson like good luck.
He couldn't even catch him.
But Anderson,
that was a crazy fight.
That was the one in the Aba Dhabi where Anderson came out,
guns blazing for like the first two rounds and then just took off hide.
Yeah,
just stop fighting for the last three
as I understand it.
That was a class warfare thing.
The play who kept taunting him and calling him playboy?
I asked some Brazilian,
why are you calling him a playboys?
I look,
uh,
it's kind of a compliment that call somebody a playboy I think in the states.
And he said Eh,
it means kind of like a rich kid who was not too serious.
And uh,
I,
you know,
obviously Anderson Silva was raised by his uncle,
his uncle was a cop and that heads parents didn't have any money at all,
didn't have the money to raise their own son,
gave him to the cup and the cup,
I don't think I had a whole ton of money.
So he came up poor and I think that's where all the shoot they box guys came
from was,
was,
was poor neighborhoods.
And so that there,
there was some rivalry there and I think that's what was going on as he knew he
could beat him up but just wanted to rough up the rich kid,
the preppy kid.
It was crazy.
But it was,
it was real weird
watch cause it didn't make any sense cause Damien Maia was never really a shit
talker.
He's a gentleman.
So to see Anderson and like screaming at him and then not fighting for the last
three rounds like that whole arena was,
they were so pissed because this was a huge event,
Nobile,
dobby,
and it was right after shake talk noon had bought 10% of the UFC.
He was kind of embarrassing for them to have that event there and have the
greatest fighter in the world at the time.
Anderson fight this guy and Damien Maia,
who's well respected and people thinking this was going to be some sort of a
crazy war and then Anderson just doesn't fight for the last three rounds.
I remember around.
I remember afterwards Dana White said,
if he does it again,
I'm going to fire him.
And I was like,
oh my God,
sweet.
Jesus is the greatest fighter in the world and that fight,
it was so bad you're going to fire him
and on that crazy.
That's crazy talk.
You know,
how do you do that?
You can't really fire somebody really fiery guy winning.
Oh for when they know,
you know.
I mean he won,
but do that and lose out.
Well,
Anderson is a crazy,
crazy sort of special example of a guy who had this aura of invincibility.
Everybody thought he was just indestructible until he met Weidman and why,
but just smashed him and then all of a sudden he's not the same guy anymore.
Like you seem in the Nick Diaz fight with Nick Diaz felled the ground and like
put his hands up like he was sleeping because he was bored with them and he's
taunting him.
And you could see Anderson was fucking with his head to the point where after
the fight was over,
Anderson fell to the ground.
It was crying after he beat Nick Diaz and he's weeping,
openly weeping.
I was standing over him.
I was doing it.
He was openly weeping just because it was so much pressure to get through it.
Because of those two fights with Weidman,
like Weidman stole something from him.
You know,
he just beat him when he knocked him out.
And then the second fight,
when he broke his leg,
we didn't just beat him.
He like stole all of his confidence.
He stole who he was as a champion.
Those moments are crazy because before that,
when he fought Stephan Bonner in Brazil and put his back up against the cage,
it's like,
come on,
try to hit man.
They just moved out of the way and then blasted them with a knee to the body and
it took 'em out and then jumped up on the cage and all the Brazilians went
crazy.
It was like,
who's better than that guy?
Who the fuck is going to beat that guy?
I mean,
wow.
Chris Weidman was watching the whole thing at home.
Not impressed.
Impressed at all.
So crazy.
It's crazy how that happens and we get this idea in our head,
whether it's a Mike Tyson or an Anderson Silva or anybody,
we get this idea in our head that you can never be beat and it's one of the
great things about this,
any sport like especially fighting is that you know this going to come a day.
Sometimes you're the hammer and sometimes you're the nail is going to come a day
when you're the nail bitch.
You know,
you better get ready for it or you better get out.
Like George Saint Pierre did.
Right.
And he's,
when he's been the nail,
you know,
he's been the nail with Matt Serra.
It's going to happen.
The,
the mental game I think is,
is way under way,
way,
way under appreciated.
And it hit me when I was a kid,
I learned that Sir Roger Bannister,
the first man to break the four minute mile,
um,
everybody thought you couldn't break the four minute mile and he finally did it.
And once he did it within like 60 days for other guys did it because they knew
it could be done.
And then when you,
when you have an idea in your head in sports,
but particularly in combat sports,
whether it's I'm invincible
or I'm going to beat this guy or whatever,
when you have that id in your head,
it's actually physically,
physiologically really,
really powerful.
But that got,
that got taken away from Anderson Silva.
He realized he was not in fact invincible.
And then I think,
I think life's a lot tougher for him now.
I thought it was way tougher.
Still my hero.
I think that's why I got like Mcgregor right now.
He literally thinks he's invincible and it's that power of his mentality that
pushes.
He literally thinks he can't lose.
He can call us fights,
call the round and he does it because he's so confident all that he believes it.
He knows it in his,
in his own head and it's,
it's powerful.
It's carries him through just destroying these guys that Chad Mendez is a good
fighter.
Chad Mendez is way out of shape for that fight.
Let's be honest about things.
First of all,
Chad Mendez and your eyes stated this and Duane Ludwig said the same thing when
I talked to him.
Chad takes time off in between fights.
He likes to go hunting.
He likes to spend time doing other shit and for him to accept a fight like down
on two weeks,
notice he did it because he thought he's going to be able to win anyway.
But if you gave Chad Mendez a full camp,
if you gave Chadman is six to eight weeks and you know,
really let him know three months preferable,
it would be a different fight,
be a very different fight as long as he wasn't injured.
And you know,
Connor actually was injured going into the fight.
He had something wrong with his knee.
He was getting stem cell injections in his name.
I heard that like eight weeks before the fight.
Now of course told me that a couple of months,
a lot of people knew about that book.
He's,
we're talking about it,
but Chad just didn't have the wind.
It was really obvious.
It was also obvious he wasn't prepared for that kind of fucking movement.
I mean it takes a long time to get ready for a guy who can kick like Connor can,
you know,
in Connor's long and big for one 45 he fucking socks a lot of weight.
I don't know what the number is,
but I know that when he was there on Wayne Day,
he looked like skeletor.
I mean he looked like total like total starvation.
And then the next day he looked big again and I'll probably put on shocked if he
was one 70 in the cage.
25 pounds walks around at one 70 I wouldn't be surprised if he was at begging
the cage.
I've known guys who cut that much weight and put it all right back on.
So cars are,
and even the guys that don't cut a lot,
the 55 is there still 68 69 they don't even have hard cuts and that's t bow.
He's like one 90 in the cage.
He's gigantic weight.
He fights at one 55 and he's fucking huge.
I mean he is a god Damn Superhero.
He doesn't even look like a real person when he gets in that cage.
He just saw muscular and thick and just,
it doesn't make any sense actually have no idea how he does it.
It's too much.
And he competes though.
He doesn't like
he has acid gas tank on.
Usually there's guys that get sucked down a lot.
They got the good round in them and they kind tired.
But tiva can fight three fives.
No problem being that gigantic after a huge weight cut.
Yeah,
well,
biodiversity is a real thing.
Some people just have abilities that other people just don't have.
Like Cain Velasquez has always had this incredible ability to have a phenomenal
cardio,
you know,
which was so ironic.
Here's another example of a guy you think he's invincible and then Fabrizio for
doom,
literally out cardio cane by training really hard and doing a lot of cardio at
8,000 feet above Avalon elevation above sea level and Co Cain does sot,
Hey,
I got the best cardio in the sport.
I don't even need to go to Mexico early.
So they're fighting in Mexico City has heavyweight to 7,500 feet above sea
level,
super high altitude,
ridiculous for heavyweights,
and Fabrizio had been training a thousand feet above that.
Now he really prepared.
He really got ready for it and you see Cain gassing and he see Cain gassing that
saccharine.
I was like,
I don't even fucking believe what I'm seeing.
Cain Velasquez is exhausted.
He's going back to his corner on rubbery legs and he's taking these big heaving
deep breath.
I'm like,
I've never seen this from him before.
The UFC had a one of their,
I don't know if it was an embedded,
there's some kind of a little,
a video that they shot of a,
a very doom in his,
uh,
in his camp.
And I saw he was sleeping on the floor.
They showed him,
he had four fighters in the room and he'd just had a tiny low,
wasn't even a cot.
He just had a pallet on the floor.
And I looked at that,
I looked at the elevation.
I was like,
this guy's going to win.
He's sleeping on the floor for two months at a time.
He's at elevation,
he's gonna win this fight.
You could sleep on the floor all day wrong.
Chris Weidman is still punching.
He'll have a nice comfy bed,
wake up with his little fucking footie pajamas on and beat the shit out of you.
I don't know if that helps.
We were just talking about wide when we were trying to figure out exactly why
he's so dominant.
And we don't have any genius answers.
Beat him up,
beat him up all his life.
His brother brutalized him,
his dad's an NFL player.
His brother was an animal and his brother bullied him.
And uh,
I think when you grow up like that and you're constantly defending yourself
against your brother,
I think that's one of the reasons why Matthews was so dominant.
Him and his brother used to beat the fuck out of each other.
I think it's one of the reasons why John Jones is such a bad ass.
Him and his brothers are all super athletes and they beat the fuck out of each
other.
I think that is super normal.
I think when you develop in a household where you're constantly competing with
your own brother and in Weidman's cases,
brother was older than him,
his brother was older and bigger.
And this isn't like a bad stories that came out of that too.
Like he had to go to the hospital once.
I think his brother dropped a weight plate on his head.
And I don't know if that's a true story,
but that's my brother and I have caused blood bloody wounds more than once
growing up.
But he still ended up a pussy.
I don't understand.
Like you got beat up this hole right here and it doesn't have a mic.
This is so fun.
Well,
I taste think that,
that there's an advantage in that psychological advantage of,
and not being afraid because you're constantly going to war with your own
brother.
You know,
you just develop a steel hardened sense of competition where you're just ready
to go.
You're ready to go.
I'm ready to go right now.
Mother,
are you ready to go?
You know,
like you have this,
like when Chris Weidman Gotten Anderson Silva's face,
when they,
uh,
first weighed in and Anderson Silva walked up to him and kissed him,
like he pressed to fate and Wyman didn't move.
And a Anderson staring at them and say,
we'll see you tomorrow.
He,
yeah,
I'm not
afraid of you,
motherfucker.
So he said,
he goes,
I'm not afraid of you.
And you could see in his eyes like,
it wasn't like,
I'm not afraid.
You,
man,
like there's no craziness.
It was just a real calm.
I'm not afraid of you man.
I'm not afraid of you.
And Weidman was like,
tomorrow we will see,
we will see.
Yeah.
But looking even there,
you see how God damn big Weidman is big and this is what he weighed in at one 85
you know the amount of weight that that guy cuts.
I don't know how much it is,
but it's not a small amount.
It's,
it's multiple pounds.
Cause when he fought Damien Maia,
that was a fight that he had to take on Fox on very short notice.
And he's sucked a tremendous amount of weight to fight that fight.
And he was just absolutely drained and exhausted because of it.
Even when they put the water back on them.
One of the things that Ray Longo said in between the corner,
he said,
I saw what you did yesterday to make weight.
If you did that,
you could fucking do anything to go out there and kick his ass.
Like he had to say that to Weidman when Weidman was exhausted.
I didn't realize how strong Weidman was until he did that helicopter knee bar
and Anderson Silva and it blew my mind as much as anything I've ever seen in a
fight.
There was a fajita talks about how the whole sport is based on holy fucking shit
moments.
Every single UFC,
at some point something's going to happen that makes you go holy fucking shit.
And that's the heart of the sport.
For me.
It was when he did that helicopter knee bar on Anderson Silva.
I'm like,
really?
You're trying to NIB arm?
And he got kind of close.
That's when I realized this mentally it's just a nother,
wasn't scared of taking them down,
I knew could take him down.
Well,
what,
what gotten me was the Vituro fight when he shot on vetoed.
That was such a deep double.
And when he shot on him and class,
there's hands together.
I'm like,
this is,
no one's defending not defending this.
And then once he got veto to the ground,
the difference between,
first of all,
the different [inaudible] veto or the veto fought Rockhold and the v toward that
flood Bisbing.
I mean,
he's just not the same dude you take away the TRT,
TRT gone,
no testosterone injections,
and he's just this fucking regular guy.
He actually has had a deficit because his body has really low testosterone as
opposed to a normal 36 37 year old man.
His body man,
he's been taking that shit for so long.
I mean,
if you go back to the Randy couture fight like we were talking about before was
240 pounds.
He's been messing with his system and hyper human levels for so long that his
regular endocrine system is probably really fucked up.
That's also the fight where Wyman gotten his face at the weigh ins and he was
yelling at him about the levels that he showed in camp because his levels in
camp were three times higher than Weidman's.
The level that they test sensible,
right.
It was under the limit,
but it was 1200 and this is a guy that needed testosterone replacement.
I mean,
it's all,
it wasn't right and it was wine and I was like,
you're fucking juice and you're fucking juice.
He goes,
I know you're fucking juice in the camp.
And he goes,
I'm going to make you pay for it.
I'm going to punish you for this tomorrow.
And you could see vittores eyes.
And he said something to him.
I couldn't hear what he said to him.
So I asked Weidman when he said,
and you know,
and he just was going off about the levels.
He goes,
I knew something was wrong with his levels,
you know,
he goes,
I'm busting my ass.
I'm 10 years younger than I am and I'm testing it 300.
You know,
and that's what,
what happens,
the guys in camp,
they breakdown mean you're,
you're going through these two and three days and you're just God damn
exhausted.
You just trying to push through it,
trying to push through it just to keep your conditioning high.
And uh,
when he found out the vittores level,
he was so angry and you could see he was so fucking angry.
And then he did punish them for it.
When he got him down.
How he beat him up bad.
He beat him up bad.
It was.
That was a bad beat down.
I never saw Vitorin that was sort of a position either mounted like that with
just no hope of getting up,
wanting to be out of there.
I've I've,
yeah,
there it is so hopeless.
He was punching up,
which we know doesn't work.
Nobody does shit.
Never wash.
He was just flailing like he was trying to hit him back and why boots?
Just smashing them.
Just boom,
boom and look on his face.
He's just so like see if you can get a video Jamie or the final flurry.
Awful.
But it saw also like vittores body when he got into the cage,
like all this loose skin,
it was all,
it was weird.
It was weird to see.
It's like he looks like a welterweight.
Like he could be welterweight like easy.
If he could stay off this shit.
He could be one 70 like and not a big one.
He would compare him to like Brandon Thatch.
Like faccia is a big welterweight.
Anthony Johnson,
when he made welterweight,
I didn't even make sense once.
I think for sure.
I made it three or four times,
three or four times a couple of times he missed it and now he has to cut weight
to get light heavyweight.
Chris and I were at masks funeral and that was the first time I met him in
person and it's one of the most fun,
like two 41 the most unbelievable things.
If you were mass funeral,
I was there too,
so we saw each other.
You remember that fucking blow hard speech that that director went up and gave
that mask died on a certain day so that he could promote the movie.
Do you remember that shit?
Do you remember that guy and I heard he barely even norm that they are now.
They were not best friends or no or I just assumed it was the best friend and he
was distraught and out.
Why he was being a blowhard.
The guy shouldn't even been able to talk at the female and then that's how
literally know him and he went up and gave this unbelievably ridiculous
Hollywood speech of mask dying at a store.
I was wondering why did he die at this time?
And then I realized he died so that he could promote our movie,
which is coming out June 20 Ballou
Hollywood.
It was so gross Hollywood,
it was so gross.
Like every you heard like,
oh,
you heard it like all throughout the,
the,
the room,
like all these people going,
Oh,
fucking Christ.
But it was one of those things where no one could say anything because you're
trying to be respectful because it's that,
you know,
this funeral.
And then like Dan,
um,
punk ass went up and told like a real heartfelt thing and you could sell it.
That was his really good friend and a brother.
And he was,
they were just,
he was really broken up and like,
you know,
Tim went up and he was really broken.
I've been in,
this guy goes up and case this fucking disgusting speech.
How disgusting.
I mean,
on a one to 10,
it was a tag as a 10.
Yeah,
that was,
that was perfect.
Lead,
disgusting.
Um,
and I,
I just assumed that he was being so inappropriate because he was broken up
inside and I asked a couple of people and like they weren't bear.
They were barely,
they were acquaintances.
He's just a fraud.
Just one of those Hollywood frog who were the two guys that tried to fight at
the dinner afterwards.
Like two guys are in the UFC,
maybe I won't name names but two guys in the UFC where the,
we would have dinner but it's still like a somber experience.
You know,
we just came from the funeral and two guys in UFC almost got into a fight at
dinner,
like yelling and screaming at each other.
If someone just said that like guys,
shut the fuck down your other book Morial dinner.
Like relax Jesus.
It's so crazy.
It's so people can't let it go.
They never,
there's no safe place at,
I'm pretty sure they never fought to this day though cause I think they're all
in different weight classes now.
But here's a,
here's the final thing with retort and Weidman.
Vito is trying to hit him with the tour,
had him hurt.
He hit him with a couple of good shots and Chris stayed right in front of them
and took the shot.
And then once he got him down,
he just started smashing them,
moved into full mount and just beat the fuck out of him.
Here we go.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Just brutalized them.
And I,
it's a,
it's an old,
old,
old line,
but you talk about punch black belt once and he's a brown belt and so on.
And now if he towards just got punched in to being a white belt,
well I don't know.
You know how good vittores tours just straight ground game is.
I've never seen him roll Jujitsu with like a high level guy.
I've never seen it.
I saw him almost catch,
he almost caught um,
Jon Jones with an arm bar,
but John counted wasn't respecting his ground game.
He's just kind of leaving it out there.
It just,
it wasn't like a difficult armbar to catch it mean any purple belt who's worth
his salt could have got that same kind of arm armbar if a guy's like doing that
with his arm.
But I wanted to love to see like,
you know,
you hear about guys like this guy's a black ball,
that guy has a black belt,
like one level.
Are they really like in a real jujitsu sense.
You know,
it used to be like 10 years ago you heard black belt,
you're like,
this has got to be amazing,
right?
And now you're here black belt.
You're like,
well,
what kind of black belt?
Exactly.
Because there are black belts in their black belts as well.
There's [inaudible] of the world.
Fucking Jesus,
the John [inaudible] of the world.
You know,
there's black belts to just chew up other black belts and his black belt to tap
other black belts,
you know,
like come come Prieto got tapped by hydro Gracie at that,
uh,
the um,
UFC event.
You know,
when they have all the grappling thing.
Yeah,
the expo.
But look competos obviously like super high level black belt,
but Hodra Gracie's level,
that's another level.
And like,
it's hard to explain that to people and they say like,
well,
this guy's a black.
That guys go,
well,
here's the deal.
That guy could do anything he wants to me but that guy could do anything you
want to him.
Like there's levels,
just level set of shovels and there's,
it's,
it's hard to wrap your and you can't really quantify it.
It's like black or purple or red or you know at a certain point in time it's
just a matter of Wa that's Hodrick Gracie and this is just all there is to it
because I haven't rolled with black belts and look pretty competitive and then
they rolled with the higher end guys and I feel like I never learned Jujitsu
wrote with Eddie tonight.
You can grow that.
He was wonderful.
Towel Roll Lips.
I can't wait to get fucking tortured by,
I have rolled away before a couple of times out here.
Wonderful time.
Good.
He actually will tie it up my years zone.
It is completely responsible for my ears.
All the cauliflower?
No higher percent.
No,
I didn't have cauliflower for seven years.
I had a fight because it's high guard is so terrified and I got hit a couple of
times so my ears were sore.
I came to la for like a month.
I trained at the lot and the first night he just put me in his rubber guard and
just shins rubbing across my ears for like four hours and I left and they were
fucking like that.
They were like,
oh,
why didn't you drain them?
I so like I didn't know about draining than back then.
This was like,
I had no idea.
I'm like,
I did not know about draining though.
It was like two,
they were doing that.
The fifties because of a role though,
there's a Roman statue,
if you've seen the statue of a gladiator with cauliflower ear that's leaking,
if it's got a Kylie my cauliflower ear and there's drops coming out of the ear.
So I have ears like this and the next night I go to the big John's gym and he
looks at me and goes,
holy fuck,
your years are big.
And he's like,
you want me to drain them?
I'm like,
I don't know what that means.
And he's like,
come with me.
And he takes me into the back and like gets,
gets needle out and drains my years and they go down.
But I never got them like cut out and stitch.
So they're just fucking big now.
Well,
they could fix that too.
My friend Brent had his ears cut open.
They filet them like a salmon and they get in there and they scrape out all the
cartilage.
I had that shit in my nose.
Oh yeah.
Well I always wear ear guards so my ears are okay.
I will look a little bit of cauliflower and little few spots,
but most of it,
it's fine.
But you're,
my nose had been broken so many times that what with cauliflower ear is,
is when your skin breaks and it fills up with blood.
The blood remains in the,
in the skin and then it calcifies.
So when the blood is trapped under the surface of the skin and bulges up and
like the little Hematoma or whatever you would call it,
that blood becomes hard.
It calcifies and literally becomes like a stone in your body.
That's why cauliflower ears are harder.
The Rock because they are a rock.
Yeah.
It's a calcium rock.
So what they can do is they cut you open and then they scrape that stuff out and
then they stitch you back up.
There's the Roman statue,
I think it's Roman,
might be Greek.
Is it Roman and Greek says Roman,
see that those cuts and it's leaking.
I mean,
that's crazy.
It's a cauliflower ear or they had it back then.
That will not only do they have color flower here back then,
but a,
uh,
an MD in New York saw this and he believes he's pretty confident that that's
actually draining an ear.
It wasn't just the guy got hit in the ear and he had a cauliflower and just he
was bleeding.
He believes that that's a medical procedure.
Wow.
And that they were,
they were cutting and draining the ear on purpose in 1100 BC or whenever it was.
That's crazy because it makes sense if you,
uh,
I mean,
you don't really see slices like that.
Right?
Right.
Too much.
He is my cousin weapon now.
Like when I'm grappling,
I like grinded into someone's head.
And the whole,
the other side because it is,
it's hard as a rock like you said.
Yeah,
look at that picture of the guy when you scroll down,
like it's on my website wrapped,
blogged about that a couple of years.
Oh really?
Yeah,
that's,
that's the,
that's the Ugi.
Wow,
that's crazy.
One of my favorite a cauliflower your stories is I shot a boxing from a DVD with
a Joe Loza and his brother Danny,
and they're boxing trainer and Danny comes in late and he's like,
God,
I can't shoot this.
Look at my ear.
And his ear was all huge and shows like,
oh,
I can fix this.
So they get a needle and a,
they go in the bathroom and Joe Jams and needle in and Danny starts screaming
and they're basically in a fist fight with each other,
with a needle through the year and somebody looks at it and he goes,
dude,
that needle is going all the way through the ear.
So the,
the needle didn't stop in the middle to drain the fluid out and it's cured all
the way through Danny's ear.
And the two of them are wrestling around with each other.
Right.
It is on video.
Well that was another example.
Two brothers,
you'd beat the fuck out of each other and they both became very tough.
There's a wrench.
You ever see the video and I'm fighting on the front lawn and their analysts and
they were fighting.
It was like NHB headbutts and Ella.
Joe used to always get the better of it,
but yeah,
he was always the big brother.
He started training first.
That's my problem.
Good man.
He just doesn't have that same like drive that Joe has like the mental side.
Danny is incredible.
He's the guy that like leaves the gym for four months,
comes in and beats up everybody.
But he doesn't have that like whatever.
They shape the like to stay in shape,
to stay motivated to stay in the gym.
Does he still fighting?
Fighting fight August 16th for local show up.
Tell him or island.
So did you train hard now?
He's trading now pretty well.
We'll see you guys.
Yeah,
and he traded a couple of other local gyms.
There they are.
Yeah.
This is like,
oh,
this is before the USC 2002 maybe.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
this is a fight.
They fight twice cause Joe wins and then Danny wants to fight again.
Oh my God,
look at this.
Yeah.
Did he win by arm bar here?
I think he does it fit.
Oh,
I don't remember specifically now.
It's so crazy.
There's brothers just,
and this is all family on the front lawn watching family and friends and like
the pig and they're fighting.
Yeah.
I mean they are fucking fighting.
This is a tight ass triangle.
Does he tap here?
Yeah,
but then he pushes him and they fight again.
There it is.
No
big biggie though.
Rough.
Huh?
Ah,
that's literally like a south shore community.
Family Street,
like neighbors are there.
Like
the cousins are there and you guys had a pig roast too,
right?
Yeah.
Well his uh,
his parents for years.
How the pig roast every summer.
So that's what we were,
there's like a hundred people there and I don't know how it even started.
It's just,
hey,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
And that was like,
what's five shorts on and a cop and gloves and the whole deal.
Funny,
Danny,
since he was 18,
it has never worn jeans without sprawl.
Shorts underneath him for his entire adult life.
He's always ready to go.
So he just takes his pants off and can fly.
You know he's,
he wears his pants.
Lewis.
He's got big jeans.
Have you seen the goals,
these pants called?
Uh,
the column,
barbell shorts,
not shorts,
a barbell,
jeans,
barbell brand jeans.
I'm wearing them right now.
These guys sent them to me,
their jeans,
but they're stretching.
Oh Shit,
dude.
They're incredible.
I think I need to really look at us.
They don't hold you back at all.
They don't,
they don't bind up at all.
Like you could throw full power kicks at least can you work out in it?
Can you say that?
Yeah.
You could do anything.
Can No,
no worry about the way your legs move half to Google.
Those things,
having tights on barbell jeans?
I have no,
uh,
they're called,
this is a company that I have no affiliation with them.
They just sent me a pair of these and I fucking love them.
They're amazing.
They make shorts now too.
So they have a,
the MMA shorts are the same material but the,
the jeans look and feel like jeans except in the way you move.
There's just some sort of elastic quality to them,
to the pants.
And this is a new company there.
I've,
I bought some before from some other companies that make them like for hockey
players and stuff because I don't fit in regular pants cause I have a fucking
troll body.
My uh,
I have a third really my,
I wear 32 but I have to wear a belt.
I really have a 30 inch waist but I have big ass thighs and so I have to like a
lot of times I wear a 33 inch pants,
straight leg just so I can get them past my mid thigh cause otherwise I can't
like Levi's five o ones are a joke.
I can't even wear them.
I literally can't get them on like they get to right here and they just lock up.
But these,
these barbell pants,
they just fit like a glove.
It's incredible.
Look at that.
Look at all their stretch was snap.
We were talking about how technology improves things.
This is embarrassing,
but I remember in the 80s I bought Chuck Norris kicking jeans.
They had ties in the front and a a pleaded crotch and the advertising.
It was the secret.
It's in the crotch.
Somehow I found that compelling and checked ours always through kicks with the
fucking cowboy boots on.
He always had those cowboy boots on with the heel.
The wooden,
he'll look it up.
Awesome
man.
Team 95 that's what I've had.
Well,
they had a gusset and then there's another band.
There's another brand called diamond gusset jeans and I used to buy those a lot
too,
and that's what they were.
It was like a regular pair of jeans,
but they put a gusset and the crotch so that you can move around better,
but none of those can fuck.
Don't buy new way.
Don't bind your legs,
but none of those can fuck with the barbell jeans,
barbell jeans,
they nailed it.
They know what the fuck they're doing.
But those tie in the front,
that's bullshit.
That's how those uh,
these to have those uh,
karate,
PKA,
karate pants.
I used to wear those with my taekwondo.
Gee,
my taekwondo,
the doe buck.
I used to wear those,
those different pants,
the,
the century pants at tied up in the front because they kicked better.
They were better.
They were looser.
They're looser on your body.
They figured out a way to make them less binding.
Like even Moy Thai shorts,
man,
a lot of them only Thai shorts fucking bind on you.
I get to see a lot.
Alan Belcher used to fight.
They'd be all rolled up,
all like got to,
they pulled them out cause Alan has those giant tree trunk legs,
you know,
and a lot of those pants they bind out like Melvin Manhoef.
He would wear like a gladiator skirt,
you know,
because his legs are huge.
I wonder if it is a,
a western body kind of a thing because I've never really seen a tie guy with
huge,
huge thighs.
Yeah.
Maybe they're designed for more slight 145 to 105 pound definite tie fighters.
Definitely.
I mean why,
why would they design them for people that don't even wear them and their world
at least.
But the um,
the thing about like guys who weight lift,
if you lift weights and you developed a big ass fucking football player thighs
or something like that,
your regular pants are just not going to fit you.
I will.
I'm always amazed when I wear XL.
I'm like,
I'm fucking five eight.
What about a real XL person?
What the hell do they were?
You know how,
how is,
how am I an XL?
What the fuck does a guy like big John Ware or Stephan struve.
I mean how many x's is in his fucking clothes?
They must be custom made.
I mean how many guys are Stephen's truths and big John has to 50 or some to 40.
I love him.
She said he was two 50.
Going to talk about his weight though.
Don't ask them about it.
Don't ask him.
Well if you go back to UFC one and you'll look at them,
then you look at them now in terms of sharing something about the dark.
Yeah,
I don't think he's two 40 I think it's quite a bit bigger than that,
but point being is he's a real XL dude.
That's a real,
I'm not fucking XL,
so what?
What?
Why do they do that?
Who the hell small?
Who the hell was wearing a small the sun oven and you have to be really fucking
a small,
would you look at that?
It's,
it's bizarre.
It's bizarre.
The sizing,
you know,
the people have,
I think in the future we're going to get all of our clothes from three d
printers.
That's what I think.
Just printed the fit.
Yeah,
I really do.
They're there.
They're doing all kinds of crazy shit with three d printers now.
I think that's probably the future of pretty much everything.
They can firearms already or arms or something that gets subject to a lot more
stress than than than closing does.
I mean,
if you can make firearms pretty soon they'll be able to make clothing on demand.
I think that's what you're going to get.
Like everything.
If you want to buy a computer,
what you're gonna do is you're gonna,
you know,
it's like buying a license
for your computer from somewhere.
You're going to get a license for it and then you're just gonna like a,
you know,
like a one click on apple or something like that and then you're just going to
print up your computer.
I really think that,
I think you're just going to have like a printer,
but that printer is going to have raw materials like metals and minerals or
whatever you need for batteries or what have you and you're just gonna print it.
Have you invested in any of that?
No.
This is one of the most,
la is one of those creative areas and the
silicone valley.
That's where all the computer stuff's going down.
You must have opportunities though to people must approach you with okay.
Kinds of stuff.
I wouldn't thinking God investing in anything.
I don't have time to do what I'm already doing.
I'm trying to size down.
I'm trying to do less shit.
The last thing I want to do is this kind of making it a t shirt here at Jamie.
Is that what this is?
Look at this how so?
They're already ready.
Look,
every time this is my problem,
whenever I have an idea,
they've already done it.
There's a video online about it.
Let me see the video.
That's it.
Oh,
okay.
So what he does is he takes,
uh,
a pattern in there,
locks in place and that's the printer.
And then it just starts adding material to that pattern.
Wow.
Makes sense man.
And then it makes it a wife beater,
put it on and you fucking go to the pizza place.
Order a slice.
It's funny that they use wife beaters,
like why they decided he's a wife beater there,
right?
That you're a target market.
The wife either market.
Yeah.
A lot of dudes.
You'd beat the shit out of their wives.
They like to make their own shirt
in the future.
Man,
I think medical technology is the most fascinating thing as far as MMA.
I about hit like healing people,
like figuring out a way to uh,
fix brains,
figuring out a way to,
uh,
people that had been injured.
You know,
people that have been KOD there,
they're talking about,
uh,
you know,
taking people that have been injured and directly putting him in like cryo
chambers and that the amount of,
uh,
damage that they can stop and the damage they can mitigate and once they can
figure out how to,
right now,
there's no real technology to reverse brain damage.
You know,
like if they break your,
if you break your arm,
they can fix it.
You know,
if you have a knee injury,
they can fix your ligaments.
If you have a brain injury,
you're pretty fucked.
You know,
there's not a whole lot they can do.
they can help you try to heal yourself.
There's a little bit of therapy they can do as a few new ways that they can kind
of mitigate the issues.
But for the most part,
when you have a brain injury,
you have a brain injury.
Yeah.
Puts you in a helmet so you will get worse.
They,
they really don't know.
I've got a friend of the family at girl I used to Babysit who uh,
had a terrible brain injury from a,
that street luge sport.
She Bang the hell out of her head and she would do,
you know,
the doctor just said don't go outside for six months and don't read any books
for six months in the reading the books don't do anything,
just cocoon your entire consciousness from the entire outside world.
Sterilize the house.
And after like I think four months she said you can get a baby chicken because
the,
you know,
don't spend a lot of time with people cause that's an awful lot of thought.
And even a cat would be too interactive but she thought a little baby chick
would be some human thing you could interact with a little bit low,
low,
low.
But you know,
at a top MD at mass general hospital saying buy a chicken to fix your brain
indicates at the level of understanding is,
as you said,
that very low.
There's not much they can do.
Don't even talk to people.
Yeah,
he do that.
She had some family money and sort of cocoon herself away.
And how old was she when this happened?
Mid Forties
Oh my God.
Mid Forties when it happened.
Yeah.
Whoa.
So she was on a street luge,
like like a skateboard type thing rolling down the hill.
I don't,
I don't understand the scope they do with the x games is like a Bob sweat on
wheels and they go down steep hills.
It makes you think about all those videos that you laugh out on live leak where
a guy gets fucking clipped on his ankles,
buy a car and flips through the air and lands on the CAC.
I can't watch it.
How many people would just get so fucked up by those things and we never think
about it again.
Yeah.
Or The guy dead UCM montage in those shows.
They get hit by a truck going across the highway.
Ah,
maybe that guy is dead or brain dead.
Well there was a guy in la that are California southern California that got in
trouble recently cause they were drifting and he drifted into a pass into a
bystander,
clipped him.
There's a video of it.
See if you can find out giappo link.
A drifter hits pedestrian and took off.
I don't know what the story is,
but they were all trying to find this guy and it was a total hit and run.
He clipped this guy with a side of his car as he was going sideways and you,
you would think you would like fall,
like got knocked back or something.
I know you flipped through the fucking air.
Like you weigh nothing.
You flip to the air like one of those little paper footballs think,
you know,
you know when you do those things,
yeah.
You remember those.
That's what it looks like when this guy gets clipped sideways on him by his
ankles and goes hurling through the air.
It's terrifying.
And now that you,
you know,
I,
my exposure to people getting hit in the head is so much more than the average
person's,
I don't think this is it,
but it's one of them.
Here's one.
Oh no,
that's different.
That guy got hit head on.
That guy broke his legs.
This one.
Um,
he got hit with the back and he goes hurling through the air.
But point being,
I can't look at those anymore and not think about the consequences.
I know there's a woman who fights in the UFC that I'm not even the,
her last fight,
but the fight before that fucked her up so much that to this day she's got all
these hormone problems.
Her cortisol levels are too high.
She gains weight and she doesn't know why she gets depressed.
She has no why her equilibrium's all fucked up and it's not even from our last
fight.
It's from the fight before her last fight.
He's,
yeah,
and we don't think about it because we watched those.
What a war.
Wow.
Those girls really fucking put it out there.
You move on,
you with your life and then she,
the lights go off.
You know the,
the spotlights are down and she's by herself.
Her fucking head is going to
the throbbing and the pain and the aches.
I'm sure both of you have experienced that before.
Every day of the week.
Pretty much at my gym.
Unlike the punching bag at my gym,
cause I'm just,
here it is.
There it is.
That's the one,
watch this,
watch this.
He goes sideways.
Watch this guy.
Oh,
see how the guy flies through the look of this?
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
That's crazy.
Right being,
yeah,
I don't want to watch it again,
but don't go to the street while people are drifting.
Right.
Cocky bitch.
Don't watch the street while they're doing it.
Yeah.
I don't know if they caught that guy and find out if they called that guy.
But the damage that these guys receive on a daily basis,
like we were talking about the Rory Macdonald fight,
or like a lot of these fights,
you watch it and you,
you don't think about it.
You just go on with your life.
But every now and then you'll run into one of those guys years later from that
doesn't fight it anymore and you're like,
whatever happened to that guy and then you'll see him somewhere and you're like,
oh shit.
Yeah.
And you'll talk to them and you'll hear him slurring their words.
I remember the first time I was a training in,
um,
in Boston and my boxing coach was this guy,
Joe Lake Kawanna training.
Uh,
Dana Rosenblatt.
I remember David Rosenblatt.
Dangerous.
Yeah,
dangerous.
Tana Rosenblatt,
who was a,
a training partner of mine.
He was one of the guys that got me convinced me to stop fighting because I
realized like I wasn't training the way he was training cause I was trying to do
comedy and all these different things at the same time,
but I was still fighting.
And then I really didn't,
I wasn't realizing how much dedication I let slip by until I watched him train.
I trained with them and I realized,
okay,
I need to get out of here.
And I'm only,
I was only 21 at the time.
He was like 17 or 18,
I think it was 18.
But,
um,
we,
we train at this gym with a bunch of like really tough guys.
And Joe Lake,
who was my boxing coach,
was that,
that prototypical South Boston boxing trainers,
fucking wars.
It was wars in the gym every day there was wars.
There wasn't no pity pat bullshit.
You,
you were going to war and I watched a few guys that I knew from a few years back
come in the gym and they would just slur and start talking funny.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm looking at fucking brain damage.
Like I'm looking at it and here's the guy that I knew five years ago and he
didn't have it and now I'm talking to him.
I haven't seen him in awhile and he's got it and it started to sink in like
these headaches and I'm getting from these training sessions like this isn't
free,
isn't it free?
I'm not,
I'm not immune.
You know like,
and you watch Joe Frazier talk on TV.
Where do you think that came from?
It came from getting punched in the head.
It's,
no,
there's no way around it
because the thing about it that I find that haunts me and yeah,
I'll be honest in Huntsville in,
in,
cause it may start happening in our sport is a CT sometimes doesn't manifest
itself until five or even 10 years after retirement.
The guy's fine could be a commentator on TVS.
Everything in his brain is working well and then five years kicks in six years
and all of a sudden he starts getting a little more aggressive and his gate
isn't as good and he said d becomes a different person and his soul starts to to
to to piss away and that,
that scary.
If that starts to happen,
it'll,
it'll give me,
that doesn't scare you Chris.
You just staring at the table.
They get about your brain.
I don't know.
I've never been really hit hard enough.
I guess I my head gigantic.
I'd never done nothing like Gary Goodrich.
Gigantic.
You guys in your gym though that have punchy,
I know guys that have fought like twice in their whole career in already.
Like they just,
that one fight did the men and they should never fight again because they're
just punchy.
Oh,
Julio Cesar Chavez and Meldrick Taylor,
they fought one time and Meldrick was never the same again.
Now who's Chavez beat him into a different person now who lost?
I was like,
Dad,
this Sean Gannon,
when you fought Kimball for a half hour,
he was never the same from that day on.
That fight was fucking crazy.
And that was an underground exclusive because everybody talked about that on the
Ugi I was streaming fight.
You set that?
I set that up.
Yeah.
That was after Kimbo had become this internet celebrity.
What year was that?
Truth was in in two.
No later than two,
five,
two,
five ish because I had to drive,
drove home from college to get to that fight.
So then when the 2002 to 2004 yeah,
I was in college in Boston,
still a so someone was like,
dude,
Kim over scans going down in that hour,
you gotta get down here.
I'm like,
Kenny Florian posted about it on the Uga pops up like he's done,
he's done.
He's back.
He's basically,
yeah,
he gets back like a week ago.
Well,
he hasn't fought in a while.
It's feelings won't get hurt as bad.
Right.
They talk a lot of shit on his commentary though.
Yeah,
I'm sure they did an excellent comments.
Taste very good.
But it doesn't matter.
People are cons.
Yeah,
they touched you and everyone who's good at their job but they don't want to
give a Falk was though people that don't give a fuck,
they're just looking to be mad at anybody but their mom or whoever's fucking
yelling at them at work or you know,
whatever your issue is,
you're taking it out on Kenny Florian.
But really you're mad that you live in your mother's basement and that's the
reality.
That's reality.
You know,
100% this,
there's a certain amount of people that are just getting fined.
People mad at anything.
But Kenny I think was posting about it on the Eugene.
That's how I found out about it because a,
I knew about Sean,
I knew Sean Gannon from the fight world and I knew about Kimbo obviously from
these youtube videos and I couldn't believe that they had actually organized a
fucking real fist fight.
And it went down.
Jamie,
pull that video up cause that's a fucking God damn crazy video.
That was the first time Kimbo fought someone who actually knew how to fight and
you know,
he became this internet celebrity by just lighting these idiots up in backyards
and we'll move away from those satellite dish.
And you know,
their metal said guy where he left on his eyeball or something or he beat the
fuck out of some people and he showed some good hands,
showed some good skills.
But then he fought Sean Gannon and Sean Gannon.
First of all he was in shape,
you know,
and he had an iron chin and he's a cop and he's got an iron heart.
He was a boxer.
Golden gloves at least though just isn't as you know,
it's not everything but he was a boxer but for sure he was in like the South
Boston.
Jim's forever like training.
He was a good vibe there.
They both came out of that wrecked and the the funny thing is they came up with
a bunch of crazy rules in this fight.
Like as it was going down,
there was a 30 count.
Mike Littlefield still has the rules written down.
He had the glasses and it's got blood on it.
It's crazy because Kimbo tagged him with a bunch of punches,
but they weren't taking them out.
And after a while Gan and started hitting the body and we started working like,
hey,
this combination mean he's tagging Kimbo and to Kimbos hanging in there and then
that Kimbo shoots,
that was illegal.
That was the first,
uh,
rule break.
But entire fight with Canon is getting a standing guillotine and he's holding
onto him in a choke.
And then all of these,
uh,
these,
that was the legal according to the rules,
that was,
he had the alligator jacket elegant a suitcase.
You guys touching them while they're fighting?
Oh No,
not them.
And he's saying,
let go,
let go.
And he's trying to pry him away and then they're prying him away.
He's like this crazy,
like what are the fucking rules?
I was very convinced I was going to get shot that night.
No,
all the Kimball's guys had been disarmed.
Well there are cops,
you know,
and then Kimbo got him down and Kimbo was trying to ground and pound him,
which was against the religion was against the rules.
So Kimbo try to ground and pound began and got back up to his feet and just
heart,
you know,
you just couldn't wear again and out that easy.
He was,
he was a guy who was used to brawling too.
He had been in the deep water before and figured out a way to swim,
you know,
and Kimball.
I don't think he'd really been in deep water.
This was like the first time hood fights for like a minute and a half long.
Now you're looking at Kimbo was already exhausted and Gannon is just starting to
beat the fuck out of him and now you know Cambos there's the punches are coming
real labor and he's trying to push Gan and off the fucking wall.
You there when we built that wall?
No,
we hit to show up early and build that wall because they didn't have one there
for this fight.
It's funny,
it didn't,
didn't last long either.
This is a crazy fight that's available online.
You can watch it.
But I remember it was a,
a bunch of us were alive watching this and commenting on the underground while
it was happening.
I was reading thread and watching the fight.
I was like,
this is crazy.
You know,
we're all trying to figure out what was going to happen.
And they showed Shawn's face at the end of it and that's when it really hit home
because you're watching,
this is all blurry,
grainy,
really shitty fucking webcam video looking.
But you see the end of,
you see the end of the video,
they get a closeup of Sean's face and
he looks like the elephant man.
Yeah,
we have all that old footage.
We own that.
We own the copyright.
How good is the footage is it gets better than the webcam stuff because they had
like at least like camcorders back then and look at his face like when,
when they're doing a 30 count and Kimbos down,
they gave him a 30 count and eventually Kimbo just could not get up well.
But look at his face and the first two times his friends just picked him up and
made them keep fighting.
He never got up from his own freewill.
But Sean just,
okay,
he got up again and he got up again.
Yep.
Cookies.
He's like,
aw,
he's up.
And Sean punched him again like after that.
It's so crazy.
I remember we someone easily could've died.
Not Fight.
Yeah,
we,
part of the,
the rules were the winners got the footage.
So what they were like six guys with cameras and so like I see Mike and those
guys,
they all had their own cameras and Sean [inaudible] and we're like,
you hand over the tapes.
So there's all this we like,
we figured they just taped the fights with is all this footage than driving up,
kept going in the hotel and go into the hotel and like,
you know,
we're gonna kill this again.
I can't probably can't use that language here.
You can look,
come on Nigga,
go kill this guy.
We're going like,
and they get there and like Rhode Island and like the bad part of the Rhode
Island and it's hilarious.
And I think I have it there.
Fuck,
I think it's still on that old computer.
I have my basement.
So Sean,
before this fight and then Sean after the fight,
what was the difference?
Totally different.
He was like,
I don't think he was ever like super smart,
but he was coherent,
smart guy and I remember seeing them like a month later and I was like,
this guy has brain damage.
Like he's like not right anymore.
Just like it had like this weird look to his face all the time.
Did he get fired from that fight?
No discipline.
Bad.
He's cop now.
Why did it?
Because that picture was on the front page of the Herald,
so it was just a bad publicity thing.
Police Union got behind him and,
and uh,
he uh,
he stayed on the forest.
Well,
it's a sparring.
It was what it was.
It was,
it was as far.
He's still on the force today.
Uh,
I haven't talked to him about six months,
but we didn't talk about work last time.
I just scroll up to that picture.
That dude's I right below that.
Look at that.
That's the dude that Kimbo fought.
What the fuck is going on with his eyes?
His,
I have a hose out.
It's not in the right place or is that what it is?
Or is it just swelling?
I don't know what that is,
is that,
that might not even be real.
That might be Photoshop,
but it certainly looks like it's eyeball's missing.
And the way Kimbo was built back then too.
It's just so he was built so much different than he is now.
Like look at that picture right there.
They lead x.
He picture right below it was get his arms up in the air.
Jamie Click on that.
Uh,
he was SWOT and he seemed,
now when he fought Ken shamrock the other day,
it just didn't look the same.
It just looks like a completely different guy.
That's the old Ken shamrock one from the one that Ken backed out of and then he
wound up finding Seth Petras.
Ellie.
Yeah,
that's
the old one.
I'm pretty sure because Ken looks younger there too.
Ken already looks fairly old there,
but Ken,
um,
backed out of the fight like last minute and then he fought South Petros.
Ellie and I knew that that was deep water for him.
I was like,
yeah,
this is not your,
you can't fight back guy.
But look how good can look there for a guy who's 51.
That was a super disappointing fight though.
I couldn't believe that everybody thought that was a word.
I do.
Not at all.
I'm not,
I just think it was two 50 year old guys fighting each other and that's just not
going to look like the best athletic competition.
I just couldn't believe that Ken couldn't finish that rear naked choke.
I thought that bring up a video of Ken from 20 years ago.
No,
he does the same style.
He cups like the top of the head.
He doesn't come behind the neck.
Like you don't have the same style of choke in 20 years ago guys didn't know
what to do.
So they tapped to it.
Yeah,
there it is right there.
You can see the picture of him with Kimbo but Kimball's not even defending and
he's not even grabbing the fucking,
I don't,
I just couldn't imagine that Ken couldn't finish that.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
I mean it might not be a word I said it looked fake as fuck cause it did kind of
look fake as fuck.
But one of the things that might've made it look fake as fuck,
cause it was a 51 year old man who was fought combat sports for 20 plus years
and his body just is not capable anymore.
I mean anybody,
I like Luke Rockhold gets your neck like that.
Can I bill?
You're going to sleep.
You know it just a fact.
But just to see Ken not be able to finish a perfectly placed rear naked choke
hand on the bicep.
You know,
most anybody who's really good at Jujitsu is going gonna finish that.
But it just doesn't make any sense.
Or even not that great at Jiu Jitsu.
Yeah,
I mean a purple belt,
a good purple belt.
But it's sad that a guy like can,
you know,
is in this position in his life when he's,
he's a legend in the sport.
You know,
you think about a guy like Arnold Palmer,
he never has to fucking work again.
You know,
you look at a,
a legend in baseball,
those guys want have to work,
have to work again.
You look at a legend like Ken Shamrock,
he just missed the fucking money.
Combat Sports are all like that though.
I mean,
look at Mike Tyson made $300 million and it doesn't have $300 million now.
That's cause he pissed it all away.
Ken Sharmarke didn't make $300 million,
$10 million a fight when Ken shamrock was good.
No,
I like the guys like the GSP or making now.
He didn't have that opportunity.
I wonder what the most anybody's ever made for an MMA fight is.
I would like to,
it would have to be in the UFC.
I wonder if it has to be a cut of a paper view on probably four or 5 million for
GSP.
I think maybe my guess is I think more than five they,
the rumor is that Mcgregor made four or 5 million and well I'm sure he had a
piece of the paper you and he fucking deserved it.
If anybody deserved a piece of the paper view,
it's Mcgregor.
We were just talking about that in the car yesterday.
Without him,
that card would have done four hundred thousand five hundred thousand buyers
instead of a million.
You know what impressed me almost as much as his performance and the fight
itself was the Irish people.
I just couldn't believe they the family.
I said that like when I did the post fight interview,
I'm like,
these people are a credible,
it's humbling that they flew all the way over there from Ireland to watch their
guy fight.
There's not,
if you had a fucking American flight,
an Ireland,
good luck getting 10 people to get on a plane and fly to America,
other sister and cousin.
It's just not the same.
And somebody was like,
yeah,
it's because they don't have anything.
So what?
It's you don't,
you don't think it's impressive that they have so much patriotism and so much
love for their country,
men that they,
they planned way in advance.
Those tickets sold out in the blink of an eye and thousands of those 15,000
people,
thousands,
like 40% came from Europe.
And it's not like a rock concert where if it's a stones cancer,
you know,
it's gonna be a phenomenal concert.
Half the people lose every fight and they could have flown all that,
spent all her money and he might've lost it.
He hadn't,
when he fought Mayweather,
a member,
they were singing all this Ricky Hatton songs.
Yep.
Right before Mayweather put them to sleep
or the frank,
if I could have been five commands about warring,
sucky fight,
he could have been.
It could have been,
but they were willing to take the chance and then they won.
He won and they won with them.
I'm telling you,
man,
you never seed celebration like that.
Every,
I had a run from place to place just to keep them getting a costed by Irish
people to try and drag you into.
My brother was out there and he said it was awesome to see like everywhere he
walked they were like crazy Irish guys.
They were so pumped up and aunt up and there's drinking.
They were singing and they were come.
I was leaving for the,
for my flight at like seven 30 in the morning and these guys were stumbling in,
still singing seven 30 fucked up.
Probably just getting home from the spearmint rhino
hammered.
It was amazing.
It's like it,
it moved me because I had been there before when a lot of Brazilians had shown
up to maybe see Anderson fight or something along those lines.
But the level of patriotism that the Irish had was on a completely different
scale.
It was just,
it was another level,
like several notches crazier.
That's why I like,
I mean for me personally,
my favorite shows are just a little amateur ones when I'm,
I'm actually coaching or somebody that I've helped train or something.
Cause he,
if you do,
the more of a connection you have with a person,
the deeper the fight becomes.
And I think with those Irishmen,
they're there.
They're so tight as a,
as a nation that uh,
that when he's in there,
they feel like they're right in there with him.
And that must make the experience.
It's also an incentive.
Maybe that photo Jesus fucking Christ,
that's a crazy photo.
Look at that shit.
11,000 people were at the way in,
right?
Guys take off their clothes in the sand,
in their underwear.
It's insane.
And the roar,
the roars that those people were cheering,
screaming when he got on that scale.
There's nothing like it.
There's no one like him.
I mean Ronda Rousey,
this is the other biggest star in MMA at this.
You know,
everybody talks about who's the biggest star in MMA?
I love Rhonda Rousey.
I think she's a one of a kind.
I don't,
I don't think there's anybody that's ever been like her.
I think she's spectacular,
but she does not have nearly the appeal this motherfucker does.
It's not even close.
How many Americans are flying to Brazil to watch her fight?
Me,
Joe.
It's my job.
I'm gone.
But I am very,
very,
very curious.
I'm going not just because it's my job,
but I'm very curious to see how they're gonna treat her in Brazil.
Whether or not,
you know,
this batch clay,
a chick has that kind of love and respect what they think she has a chance.
What kind of crowds going to show up?
What does it going to be like if Rhonda Beats Her
when Rhonda Beats?
Or should I say,
I mean,
anything can happen.
Anything can happen that I learned that in the late nineties or could have been
the,
I was the late nineties,
uh,
pep touch fought Dan Severn and I got the tape afterwards from a,
for Monte would promoted it and they,
they're doing the preflight interview and they say,
uh Oh pat,
what do you think's going to happen?
And Pat goes,
I don't know what's going to happen.
That's why we're having the fight.
And he was fighting,
guy was a hundred pounds heavier than him and I think it ended up being a draw
but cause nobody tapped anybody.
But Pat,
pat really did win that fight and ever since then I've been like,
you don't know what's going to happen.
That's why I have the fight.
I mean,
yeah,
fights are crazy.
Throw bones of people.
You Zig when you should have zagged and pretty sure we were all thinking when
Anderson Silva Beats Chris Weidman and what's next?
I didn't then that now new radio.
I didn't think I did.
I did not think that.
Oh I was saying,
I mean I wasn't lying when I did that pre fight thing.
I'm like,
this guy is different.
He's,
he's,
he's a special kind of a destroyer.
You know,
there's something about Weidman.
He's so fucking stupid.
Is that something,
because the three of us were talking about it in the car yesterday.
What is it?
I don't know.
I had met some guys have it.
Some guys don't.
You know,
it's like,
what is it that makes a guy that fucking good?
I don't know what it is.
There's intangible qualities that some people possess and he's born that way.
These moon,
it's all of the above.
What we talked about,
his dad was in football player.
His fucking brother beat the shit out of them.
All that stuff I'm sure has an effect on his mental state and his,
his resolve,
his,
he has unflappable,
will unflappable resolve.
Like he's just got this iron will and you just sense it when you look at them.
You sense it when you see him fighting.
Like you got to beat that fucking guy.
He's not beating himself and he's skillful.
He's very good,
very well prepared.
Toughest Shit can knock guys out,
can knock guys out with their hands.
You ever see him fight Uriah Hall and bring a fire?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It caught your eye hall with his long left Hook boom and put them away standing
me.
He puts guys away standing puts Mark Munoz away with that fucking brutal elbow.
Oh,
he's no joke,
man.
He's an animal,
you know.
And now as a middleweight champion,
what's fascinating right now is now that he's passed v tour,
which was,
is sort of a mandatory fight.
There are so many good fights there.
There's Jacques Perrey,
you'll Romero Luke Rockhold.
Fuck man.
There's some mother Isro lining up.
Oh God.
You know,
I mean in the way Rockhold beat down Machida Foch and then the Ray Romero did
the same goddamn thing he beat him down to,
it's like the,
the,
the contenders are rising to the top.
They're clearly being established and Jack Hurray.
I mean,
fuck you want to talk about Worldclass Jujitsu?
That guy's insane.
He's insane.
He's so fucking good and so strong.
It's the tool five division I felt like with five years ago or four years ago or
something was kind of like they had John Jones on top and everybody else in the
top 10 was a killer.
But it's definitely one 85 right now.
Jewel fives actually,
they're pretty weak right now.
That division.
Right.
Well you know Joan relatively,
hopefully Jones comes back eventually gets his life in order and it comes back.
That situation is so sad and you know,
you're not hearing anything from John,
you know,
I'm sure he's got all sorts of legal problems.
Just gets you to stay out of the media and just take care of his shit right now.
Which state,
you know,
clear,
clear his mind and his life and make restitution and do whatever he's got to do
and hopefully he'll be back again.
But you want to talk about talent?
Hopefully man,
he,
I want to see him back,
like get this shit together and come back and just be on top again.
Because that guy was incredibly talented.
I watched all his fights because he grew up fighting and Massachusetts,
cause New York,
they couldn't fight.
So all his fights were in Massachusetts and I saw that kid fight like three
times.
Like this kid's got it.
Like this kid's going somewhere.
He fought six times in three months.
Did you get to the UFC three months,
six times three weekends in a row once and it took a last minute fight in the
UFC.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was incredible.
My first experience was I was cornering somebody at a show in Massachusetts and
Chris,
I think my guy lost.
I'm just kind of sit in their arm around them,
giving him water or whatever.
And Chris goes,
there's this new guy,
he says it's a fight and it's only the five seconds you can come here.
And so he grabs me and we go running up to the cage and it was over the flight.
It ended in 19 seconds and I know the guy fought and the guy fight is like tough
and got crushed by him.
And Chris just said,
this guy is going to be the,
he's going to be the next one.
Wow.
That's amazing.
He's a murderer.
So lucky he never fought Tom.
He was supposed to fight Tom Walla for the like local title.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause Tom Lawler fought master.
He's a Massachusetts guy originally.
And this was to fight for the title.
I had set it all up for Tom and I'm like,
oh,
he looks good,
but Tom,
you can fight him.
And like a week later the UFC call Jon Jones and I'm like,
thank God that I never happened.
Or total I guess talking about,
I never had a UFC career.
I mean,
not to say he would have lost for sure,
but it was a tough fight to take,
you know,
in retro said he would have lost for sure.
What are you doing when you're lying to people?
Anything can happen.
And it happened in the fight and Tom hits hard.
So.
Yes.
I mean it does.
Most people thought he was gonna lose this fight last weekend.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it was a tough fight for him for sure.
I'm getting beat up and he had taken 27 months off.
Ring.
Rust is real.
Why did it take so much time off?
So I cornered him,
and this is funny,
according to him in that Mega Kuyper fight in Sweden and uh,
we walk in after the first round and you look to this as like,
I think I blew my fucking knee.
Now I'm just like,
what do you mean you blew it might blew my knee.
And so the other corner is a Jiu Jitsu coach.
He's like,
you should sit down.
I can't,
I won't be able to get back up.
Whoa.
And we're like,
all right.
He's like,
what should I do?
Should we not fight?
And like,
do you want to fight?
He said,
yeah.
So go out there and stand up.
And he guillotines the guy in the second round,
chokes him unconscious and he tore his ACL,
completely blew his ACL.
Wow.
And so he recovered for like a year and then blew his meniscus and the same
knee.
And so then another six month recovery and just then he had a book of fight and
get back in shape is just injury after injury and the same knee.
What a guys do.
I've always wondered,
what does a guy like Tom Lawler who doesn't make that much money,
what do they do for money when that happens?
Oh,
Tom's made some good money in the UFC that he could sit on and Thomas Filthy.
He doesn't like need nice things if you've ever,
so he won a bonus at UFC 100,
which was $100,000 and he went and bought a condo in Providence,
which it wasn't expensive.
Like bought it straight out and in Rhode Island.
Yeah.
And he's from that area.
Like no he did.
He lived there for years because he used to,
um,
that's where he grew up like Swanzi Summerset area.
And you like real island cause everything's a small city.
Everything's close.
And he looked in the nastiest condor you've ever been in.
It was like cat piss everywhere and like just like smell the,
you know,
everything,
it was terrible.
But you know,
he doesn't need all the money.
So for him,
like $100,000,
it was like five years of living cause he doesn't need,
you know,
Nice Amenities,
nice things.
And you just teach you Jitsu here and there and do seminars and I don't think
he's,
I don't think he's worked a regular job since,
since after four or five.
Then new music,
like the high school history teacher for awhile and then just got in a fight and
then that's it.
He just figured out the way they survive on,
you know,
not having a lot,
it's a hard world out there for guys who are like the lower level guys that are
trying to make it.
It's very,
very hard world.
very difficult for those guys to to make enough money to actually get by.
It's terrible.
I have a guy that fights in the UFC now that went back to having a real job full
time,
still fights but has a job.
He's a corrections officer who was on Joe proctor.
He has a full time job now.
He's six fights in UFC,
UFC career and has a fulltime job watching inmates.
Plymouth County.
That's crazy because he used to suck job too,
by the way.
He had a training partner,
horror fucking stories where people throwing shit on them and oh yeah,
they would,
they do that.
They throw shit at you.
There was a guy who used to help out from,
from a master's,
there's actually from Connecticut and it was,
it was a good fighter.
He,
I think he probably had Europe see potential and then he
decided just not,
the future's not for me and so he,
he told me,
no,
I,
yeah,
I got sort of bad news.
I'm going to go to law school instead of
fighting.
I was like,
hello.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
What do you do when a guy's going,
going through your jam and he wants to fight and you know,
he's got no shot.
Do you just say,
look,
you've got to figure this out for yourself.
Like if you,
you,
you got a guy who's uncoordinated and just,
you know,
not tough,
but for whatever reason decides to,
to fight,
tell him it's not for them.
You tell it straight up,
tell them you can't,
you can't fight from here.
I said,
there's unscrupulous promoters that are looking for sharks versus fish.
I explained the whole deal to warm it though,
how the sport works at the low level,
there's big ticket sellers.
They're going to sell 200 tickets at $50 each,
$35 each.
And the promoters always looking for some fish to feed the,
to feed to the sharks so that the guy,
I'll have 200 friends show up in the next and when,
and the next town in order to say,
you can get a fight,
like there's a million and scope of his promoters in this state that will give
you a fight,
but it's not good for you.
Um,
it's a dangerous sport.
Does,
so you can't fight out of here.
And,
uh,
sometimes they keep going,
but not usually,
you know,
if you could,
cause it's,
it's not the type of sport where you can be nice to people.
It's,
it's,
it's too important.
Um,
you know,
if you tell a girl she's pretty and she's not or something,
there's no bad consequences.
But if you let somebody think they have a chance at fighting and really they're
not very good,
they can get a scrambled brain.
So I tell people,
don't do that,
man.
A lot of people just let them figure it out for themselves.
Yeah,
I see it in other gyms are Jim,
if you don't think you're ready to fight,
you don't fight.
And the guys will leave.
They'll go to the taekwondo school that lets them fight MMA with no experience
and then just see them get killed.
Cause they're just not prepared.
Guys that come to Raj,
I'm don't fight for years.
Even amateurs,
they come in and they learn everything.
They learn how to Bristle Jujitsu.
Kickbox and then maybe we,
if you think they're ready,
you take a fight.
What's your gem?
So people will listen.
A Lowe's or on MMA back in Massachusetts at j use z.
O n right?
Yes.
Lozan MMA.
Uh,
we've got to wrap this up.
Anything else you want to say?
Mixed martial arts.com the website.
Fuck the,
Oh gee,
fuck.
Oh Gee.
I thought it was fuck that Uga.
I guess
fucking both.
Okay.
Well you guys
that series,
seriously,
the best mixed martial arts website in the world.
Uh,
you guys are always on top of the news.
He always miss spell people's names.
It's great.
You misquote me almost every time,
every day.
Uh,
but it's,
uh,
like as far I,
I still post all the fucking time.
I'm on the last of the Mohicans.
I'm still in there getting shit on call a fag and whenever they want to call me
Dick,
Dick Rider,
no matter what you're going to get shit on.
But I think overall,
I,
I look at it the opposite way.
I'm a,
I'm an optimist.
I think it's like 10% douchebags 90% cool people maybe.
But either way you guys have fucking made it through the storm.
That was the beginning of MMA and I think this website was an integral part of
keeping the,
the core fanbase alive.
So a character,
thank you very much for everything that you've done.
A really,
really appreciate.
It gave me a place to waste a lot of fucking time and uh,
talk a lot of shit about all kinds of different fights and read a lot of cool
information and news and whenever anybody's hurt or breaking news,
I always find out about it on the underground.
Imagine if you track the hour he spent on like how much would that be of your
life while I was one of the first 400.
So shit,
it would be a lot 15,
17 years at an hour,
a couple hours a day.
And a lot of God damn waste of time.
But thank you.
I don't want to be an ass kissed,
but uh,
but I,
but I will be as I've told these guys before,
when there's a UFC that you're not on it to me.
And again,
I don't want to sound like an ass kiss,
but it's just what I've said,
not in front of you,
but to these guys previously.
It doesn't feel like a UFC without,
without you there.
The weigh ins aren't just,
it's just not the same.
So thanks to you for making the UFC the UFC for,
for me.
Well,
thank you very much man.
I appreciate it.
All right.
Mixed martial arts.com go check it out and,
uh,
love the Ugi.
Loved the Oji.
Take it easy.
Everybody.
Cheers.
I've told people the hardest thing.